all right and we are live the last word
with laura cognito igbontis and ty guy
travis special thursday edition like i
like it
how are we doing
doing good um i don't even know what
just happened with nintendo but i don't
really care i've been playing finished
death loop i rolled the credits on that
that was
so much fun um and then i'm about five
hours into kena as well so it's just
been a fun week on top of trials which
we will definitely talk about playing
over the weekend and sad bethune is just
straight up calling us out so we got a
lot of fun stuff to talk about travis
what you been up to man
welcome to fire team chat oh sorry uh
uh
yeah doing good i'm sure i've been
really good just blowing my mind
sorry that was one of my uh
that was one of my deceptions as uh
travathune
uh one of the oh my god
the
hive
uh
yeah uh no i'm doing good man it's been
super busy week i i
just got enough time in to do all the
destiny stuff so i'm i'm and go flawless
obviously and all that which took no
time because now it's one card and
you're done uh that's trials the game
mode um
yeah
but uh yeah i also carried someone and
it was like so easy anyway we'll get to
that um but yeah i'm doing reviews i
reviews
i reviewed sable okay an indie game that
came out uh today yesterday something
like that uh which was really good you
can read my review on ign and uh
previewing a game doing another review
this week and yeah it's just been really
busy so it's been good uh how about you
[ __ ] what have you been up to
nothing probably i'm just sitting around
we're getting the trials of course you
know doing that and uh
just it's busy man there's a lot of
stuff going on we just came off that
nintendo direct there's a lot going on
but uh we got to bring somebody in we
got this special guest in there right
of course let's hear it
let's do it man welcome to the last word
episode number 167 into glorious
thursday we're back in front of the
campfire for some more lunar shooter
discussion
i'm extremely excited about our
returning guests so we're going to get
right into it
i want to introduce a lord who is not
only a great friend to the campfire who
presents a unique combination of high
quality game journalism and informative
pop culture videos all done with the
utmost passion for the luna shooter
genre
introducing the creator and host of the
poltassi youtube channel renowned
science fiction novelist and senior
contributor to forbes.com
the lord of cookie clicker
recent trials bounty victim
yet sideshow to the real star of youtube
everyone's favorite co-hosting corgi
that eevee tassie
live from ohio and making his return
into the campfire of the last word
my man lord paul tassie how we doing sir
good good that never gets old
evolves over
just be like i wrote his i'll just
repeat it that doesn't work i can't
believe you didn't put travis's best
what's friend on how's cookie clicker
going man yeah what is that what the
hell is that you bring it on
the boys
i had to quit once i downloaded diablo
because i could only have one addictive
game running at a time so
i think i'm gonna put cookie clicker i
didn't know it was on steam so i'm like
oh my god cookie clickers on steam i got
to get it and
it's still cookie clicker and it's still
very addictive so
it's it's dangerous
this is a mobile game that you became
absorbed in and now are like a
spokesperson for an unofficial
spokesperson yeah no i am officially
sponsored by cookie clicker they are
actually paying for my appearance here
tonight so yeah
give a 15-minute pitch about cooking
they're the less known youtube sponsor
most people go with raid shadow legends
but cassie tassie chooses cookie clicker
great raid shadow cookies yes
that sounds like something from
dave lavonte
i know i give you guys the run around a
few times there no no you're good you're
good for show with travis on it it's
great
wait wait wait wait you've never you've
never met traffic you've adopted this is
so cool yeah no here yeah
they did adopt me i was like i guess i'm
going to start my own youtube channel
now that fireteam chat's over
i don't know how do you want to go with
us yeah yeah pretty got to bring them in
these these wayward destiny youths
that's right
our destiny podcast only made it for 300
episodes i guess i go to go find
somewhere else
we're halfway halfway to your now right
yeah
my lonely solo queue finally found a
fire team to sit with once again podcast
matchmaking yeah
was this skill based or just like
connection based really definitely not
definitely not skill based
what's happening what's everybody doing
with this game everybody's screaming at
each other in destiny that's what it
seems like if you follow destiny twitter
because nobody seems to agree
uh the big prolific people they have
opinions about one thing all the replies
of casual people have others there's
debates going back and forth
yeah did you guys play last weekend
and the weekend before since we had this
whole debate
so the big curiosity is matchmaking
trials flawless and all that fun before
we get into that one i gotta let our two
guests not guests i'm sorry gotta let
our co-hosts and our guest he was a
guest but now they're definitely going
to go and talk about the thoughts call
me a guest today i'm going to act like a
guest today oh okay yeah my plan
i'm not going to be asking any questions
i'm just going to have a really strong
opinion
so before we get into that paul can i
just ask you like we've only got to
speak one time since uh the season
started and i think it was like the week
that the season started so uh we've been
talking about our various opinions on
this panel about how we think the
season's going and how it stacks up to
other non-expansion seasons where do you
stand just in general with the season
what do you think uh i'd like it so far
i
i think it is extremely buggy to the
point of
it's it's hampering the season i think a
little bit because it feels like every
week there is
some sort of progression bug uh in place
that is is kind of putting a damper on
things
um i i like the return of mara and kind
of how they're flushing out saboteun
more i am i'm curious where this whole
season goes because like this storyline
we're currently in should be over in
like
three weeks
and i think at most so like something is
gonna happen and i we're gonna it's
gonna take a turn somewhere else so
i think once that happens i think i'm
i'm the most curious about that but in
terms of activities uh when when astral
is working i like astrul and then i
really like the shattered realm i think
that is a
a brilliant location that they have
really done a great job with in terms of
balancing kind of
puzzle exploration and combat and i
enjoy how they're adding to it every
week which has been kind of really fun
to find all the new secrets except this
week where the freaking data catches are
so
it is you don't show on your map you
have to have true sight on i'm like all
right i got to look up a youtube guide
for this because you can't just find
them randomly it's like impossible so
yeah the first one that i found because
i was going through making my guide for
those yeah first one literally popped
like i was like going through i'm like
okay so i went through i did the first
ascendant mysteries he actually teleport
to the other island i was like cool i
thought we'd teleport here and then i'm
going down i'm like okay so here's a
chest out oh what is this little floaty
thing i pick it up i'm like that's what
it like they're so hard to see in the
one i think i saw it was maybe your
tweet or somebody else the one on the
island
near impossible to spot in that like
slow field unless you just
know exactly where to look shout out by
the
way
sorry yeah no shout out first yeah shout
out mega
5591 for the super chat paul where is
use cookie well i'm baking like eight
million cookies an hour in cookie
clickers okay so we'll get you we'll get
you one soon right all right no the the
the slow field one it was like lying
about where it was it's like oh it's in
this part of the map it like names part
of the map and then when you're standing
at it it's it's a different part of the
map and you're like what this is not
what they told me so yeah
one was like confusing one was overly i
was like harbingers it was like uh
the derelict shipyard and all of a
sudden that's the one that's way out on
the vista island i was so mad because i
was like doing it live on stream i'm
like where's this thing i'm like okay so
i'm like picking up the true sight run
back out into the derelict where like
beacon two is i'm searching every corner
nook and everything come back i'm like
doing laps and laps and laps i'm like
it's got to be over here
some somebody else in my chat's like
well hey let me go check the island i'm
like son
so yeah no those were those were sneaky
for sure what i like the most uh the
things they have added i don't know
about the data caches but the stuff they
did like the scorn gladiator match that
you stumble upon like it's very cool
just in terms of like it's awesome being
a fun little thing then mara has
commentary on it yeah i thought that was
was really interesting i like when they
do stuff like that for sure
yeah absolutely yes a bit for me i mean
i've been i've been enjoying it quick
question for all of you did you guys get
the passcode to that that track that
chest in there where it's like it's like
covered i don't know what i did but
that's that's the thing so you have to
find and kill three different yellow
bars that are like around the area and
each one has a passcode so you just
caught it
and there's a little fire i've got a
video for that
i didn't know what to do and that i had
to come back and do it at a different
time uh so it was
yeah yeah i like accidentally
i like tripped my way through that first
yeah i haven't been using uh guides for
any of this and i've just been like
organically figuring it out because you
know they tell you like that there's so
many ascendant mysteries or whatever so
i figured that one out organically and
it honestly it's just been so great to
feel like there's like exploration and
stuff to discover in destiny rather than
just going like all right i know exactly
what i'm gonna have to do this week
right i'm just gonna repeat what i did
last week and i'm gonna get the drops
that i know i'm gonna get and all that
stuff like for me destiny is one of the
things that draws me to destiny is like
the the mystery of like what's that new
exotic i don't know about yet and what's
that new dungeon i haven't tackled yet
and so this has been my favorite season
not because of the six person matchmade
activity i still hate all of those
including this one
but it's it's just the fact that there's
a place to explore that feels fresh and
has mysteries and
uh the time-gaining doesn't bother me
because they're doing it cleverly like a
metroidvania where you're gaining access
to different areas every week as you get
new abilities which i just think is
awesome yeah that was cool
i had um i like the the one with the uh
scoring
ball thing and you got to go to
different locations charge that up i
thought that was interesting um
yeah it's been fun it's been fun astral
alignment for me i've been actually
surprisingly impressed with uh ages was
it age receptors that's the name of it
yeah i'm really enjoying that i i just
got the catalyst to drop oh he did i
still don't have it
yeah it reminds me of uh it reminds me
of trinity ghoul in its effect where you
know where you'd get a kill and that
would just do like the blast the blast
radius yeah stasis yeah yeah it's like
pairing it with a stasis build is so
much fun
i love the aspect of it obviously i
haven't unlocked the catalyst yet where
you use the super to um to to kind of
make it have higher dps but i like that
type of utility and um i've been rocking
that the battle harmony as a warlock
build oh man it is it's so much fun
that's a wall like this thing yeah again
it's it's wild the cabbage is gonna talk
about the catalyst cause like i was
playing
uh arms dealer and like i went into the
tank room
and i i activated the super mode and if
you have whisper bonds on you're getting
super every time you you shatter an
enemy so like i i had it on for the
entire room both tanks just clearing
clearing every enemy with the
supercharged beam and the tanks because
you're doing so much damage and if you
can like kind of time it and just keep
it running and running and running like
it is it's a better use of a super
probably than your actual super would be
in a lot of circumstances like i don't
know if that's always true but in a lot
of you know especially you know really
crowded rooms where you can always just
keep it up
it's it's definitely great and it
refills your ammo because the whole
point of it is when you kill something
with freeze damage you also get ammo
back and it has like a 200 round
magazine when you pop the super part of
it so
it's it's one of the crazier catalysts i
think i have ever seen yeah it it it is
interesting coming one of my favorite
exotics bought by far e did you get it
yet you you got you know you dropped the
catalyst i don't have the catalyst yeah
i got the gun i don't have the catalyst
yet um unlucky not as as to cross
unlucky he took 34 runs
i was like yikes uh was datto looks 14
or something i think i'm like almost up
to 10 now or something so not in the
lucky side unfortunately
i didn't even know it dropped from
astral alignment but i've definitely
done like 10 or 15 alignments since i
got that uh exotic and i still don't
have it so i just well it started
dropping this week not last week so okay
yeah just here probably probably more
like 10 than i've done yeah yeah but
you're lucky with me
yeah crazy utility it's it finally got
me to take my vex with the class off it
finally got like i've been vex has been
glued to me bro like i have no idea but
yeah that thing is so cool like i said
the stasis build the intellect builds
all that having fun with that obviously
we'll get in the trials but yeah i'm
having fun we're gonna touch this law
because
man there's some stuff to talk about
there too
yeah i'm going to lock it down i think
mara's going to die
i know every time i talk to somebody
about this they go they can't kill mara
she's too important to the story and i'm
like bro they're giving the hive
ghosts you know what i mean like they
killed kade like these guys i don't
think they care anymore i think they're
just like look we've had so many years
of the story not really going anywhere
and every single expansion ends with
like oh right over the horizon something
is finally gonna happen in this game and
i think they're at the point where
they're like all right we got three
years to kind of wrap up this arc stuff
needs to start happening quickly and not
even in like main seasons like even in
off seasons big stuff can happen like
they they killed off all the factions
all three of them in like one
it was it was sort of like one line of
dialogue at the end of last season so i
was like i i just really don't think i
don't get what why people think that
they would be afraid to kill her i i
respect how brazen that was with the
factions it was so brazen
i honestly think that's not really a
reason to not do it and all of the stuff
they're setting up kind of is showing
like
like clearly the crow is part of
sabathun's plan to to to take power mara
is just playing right in the sabbath's
hand and being super arrogant about this
like oh yeah whatever i'm immortal i've
got a throne world and i just think like
some stuff is gonna happen and i i don't
think mara is going to make it through
the season personally paul let me get
you a thought because you had a good
video
about this whole situation and it's
savvy dunes you know a little little
sharp jabs at us man that one this look
was hilarious the third wall rrp
disrespects
let's get to it therefore what are we
feeling then what's everything says
things like r.i.p cade that is
to me that is fourth wall breaking like
that is talking to us the player not
yeah guardian
i find hilarious um
i haven't thought too much about mara
dying i i i'm not gonna rule it out i
can see it happening i would i guess it
would be a little surprised given that
we just sort of hinged last season on
lakshmi dying and that was a major
character
uh so to kind of just do that again here
uh instead of maybe pushing it to the
witch queen
i i'd be a little surprised um i i there
was all the speculation this week about
if osiris is already dead or not i feel
like they wouldn't
have set things up this way to
ultimately reveal that osiris has been
dead the whole time i would be a little
surprised if that's
how this ended there um
in terms of mara it's just
i i don't know if she's gonna die but
like she man she has become like
exponentially more dislikable like i get
that a lot of people are like you're
just not realizing this like she's
always been like arrogant self-serving
but like
boy is it really coming across
emphatically this time and in addition
to that it's also like her plan just
seems very stupid and like part of that
is
you know just
not thinking you can outsmart that
savithune but this season is also weird
because like we know what happens when
savathune
escapes and gets the light and isn't
killed so that kind of creates a weird
storytelling barrier where like i i
can't imagine just in three weeks
sabbath breaks out of her cocoon and
pieces out and that's like the end of
the story no way like there has to be
more
yeah going on over the next six months
um it could involve mario dying i feel
like if mara died right now like who
would really be sad like petra
um
would be weird it wouldn't be because
crow doesn't even know but he would just
be weirdly divided to be like i think
there's part of him would be like this
is weird but yeah he wouldn't be hurt
right now but it is weird to see like
everything that's been going on humanity
loses a huge ally i think that's the
major blow because it means like now
we're even more undefended because mara
has kind of like stood up for us and
protected us at really key moments
including like you know the last wish
and oryx's invasion i think that if she
dies it just adds to like the stakes of
like wow we're really screwed here like
things are looking really dire and that
seems like what they're doing generally
with the narrative they're trying to
like build up our allies in certain
areas and then take away our safeguards
in other areas and just like set us up
for this final you know uh confrontation
that's what i'm thinking but i mean i
i'm still i saw the ultimate theory that
savithun will be an ally eventually i
i don't think
again it just seems too straightforward
to me that the plot of the witch queen
is the hive get the light
we get mad about it we go to a throne
world we kill sabbath as the raid boss
like
to me that is much too straightforward a
plot line especially after building
saboteun up for this long we might fight
her and fight her armies and stuff but i
i would be surprised if we
ended the witch queen without some sort
of allegiance with her
against the voice in the darkness
because like
she's making it very clear that is her
like ultimate enemy like yeah she wants
to steal our light but like
who doesn't want to steal our light i
mean everybody wants to like
so
because
we know the raid actually isn't against
sabathun because they say something is
like trapped down in there in the
pyramid ship they actually said that on
the website for which clinton so she
yeah i've said that she's not you're
fighting you're fighting the darkness
i've always thought it was wrath to be
the rape boss because i i assume we're
not going to fight zebra rat this season
no like that i wouldn't imagine that i
don't think that's going to happen so
like it would make more sense if it was
either zebu or wrath or some sort of
like
manifestation of a voice in the darkness
yeah or something or i don't know one of
the pyramid statues
apparently the pyramid is in her
throne world it's like not a real place
so it it could have theoretically
anything inside of it it doesn't even
have to be like real or canon it's like
a fictitious area right throw a throne
worldwide object really kind of messes
yeah
we're like does anything matter in a
throne yes exactly
yeah i don't really get how throne
worlds work either but yeah it's like
the matrix where you die in the throne
world you die in real life like yeah
that's the only thing i can gather from
it but
i think
i'm just gonna read the raid piece real
quick just among the swamps of
savathun's throne world lies a sunken
pyramid alongside your fire team venture
inward and confront the ancient danger
imprisoned within so i don't know what
ancient danger would be buried in a
pyramid in her own world
right i don't know why i think it's
whatever but i don't want zebra wrath to
be imprisoned in a pyramid so maybe not
i don't know right yeah i don't think so
i think i think it's whatever savathun's
afraid of which does speak to her
possibly being
an ally if you're just hanging out in
their throne world and you have to think
about it her throne world is going to be
traversable for the next couple of years
in destiny you got it
until the end of the darkness and light
saga so if we kill her does her throne
world exist like i i'm not even really
clear on that either she's in an
interesting spot because she from my
understanding with the law stuff i've
been reading is just that she's kind of
been like a heretic against her own like
you know a lot of the other hive are
denouncing her and the thing right now
out of her worm that's pretty bad
and then the other thing is we we're
hearing obviously i mean i heard which i
didn't realize was um
it was zevo wrath who took osiris like
from my understanding and then um
it's just it's she's she's she's playing
this high-stakes poker game of pitting
everybody against as far as getting the
light and then pitting people against
each other but yeah right now she's not
beloved by the hive like she is clearly
doing her own thing and almost you know
denouncing like sore logic in a way so
that that part is very interesting to me
i don't know about maori man like
i it part of me i see both of you asides
because part of me is like we just
she was just reintroduced again after
not seeing her for a while you know it
seems like it was largely true but it
see it seems the vibe i've gotten lucky
to me would just make the tower great
again i thought she was always a side
character
to be completely honest i never took her
seriously like sorry future world cup
fans i just that was disneyland herself
yeah she you know i remember going to
that faction they had the starbucks wifi
cafe set up over there that that was
that crew you know salute to them but at
the end of the day like to me it's like
kadle you know
mythrax you know like with these uneasy
alliances and histories that we've had
with the past to now
have to formalize against these greater
evils so i would be shocked it would be
bold if they did it i would be shocked
if they did it but i still see her
thinking around but i will agree with
paul she has become extremely
unlikable
and very fine and did y'all catch that
conversation she had
with ikora and regarding um
uh aldrin and he's you know you exhumed
him and like her wanting vengeance and
akora trying to say hey you need to let
it go because of what that was
that was an intense conversation yeah so
like she i think they're fleshing her
out a little bit more my gut says she's
sticking around but i'll tell you i'll
tell you this travis i there's a part of
me that wouldn't be upset if she goes i
would just be surprised you know say it
it's very interesting what's going on
yeah i was like i didn't see her
becoming adversarial if a path opens for
us to become allied with sabbath noon i
don't think mario would let that happen
that's a good point too so i mean a lot
of people would be mad about that oh
yeah the first thing that people have
brought up
uh
in the past is where's eris in all this
yeah i've been wondering for a long time
have such a personal yeah against each
other like
it really seems like she has to be in in
which queen although you've seen
all we've seen is like horror which
means so far so
i i don't know i i i don't know why they
wouldn't bring her in i i assume her
voice actress isn't one of like the
the hollywood people they need to recast
or something
so yeah i it seems like it would be time
definitely to have her in the witch
queen so i'm hoping we we see that i
mean she was in beyond light quote
unquote but all she did was go to europa
and do nothing and say nothing so
yeah i just gotta say like the actress
for savithoon deborah wilson i think it
is every like time you go up and listen
to her and this week especially when
it's ripcade what do you think you're
going to do with that weapon
with that little gun yeah i was holding
a bow so a little breaking bro broke it
a little bit for me but
still like i had a tiny hand cannon and
i went um
it's the chosen weapon
the way they've been building her up and
they got like a voice actress who's like
nailing her role she's very good i don't
think
like again mara
it's interesting because like her
connection to crow is
so far back that we've seen because the
connection with her even floating the
crowd clouds in like season of the
drifter with like the nine and she's
communicating with them like i feel like
her history is so big that like if
something does happen to her i don't
know what it's gonna do i'd like to see
her get developed more
i'd rather her not die because i think
keeping her around will keep more things
interesting than killing her off because
her and crow going at it petra being
around and then savathu and this whole
clash of ideals going on
i don't i'm just curious what the
commentary is going to be like between
ikora mara crowe
aerys and then all of a sudden if we can
communicate with sabathune at the same
time i just want to be a fly on the wall
in that conversation between those four
or five characters just to be like
most conversations so yeah yeah
so if you want a bit of wholesome um
content get get the catalyst complete
the catalyst and claim the triumph for
the ship and read the ship lore and it's
all about mara uh being very nice to
petra actually about how she did such a
good job omaro was away and it's
actually kind of sweet so it's like wow
the first stupid bit of mara content
i've seen in a while uh another
interesting thing that mark brought up
in i think it's dialogue at the end of
either an astral or a shattered realm is
i think it's her nikora talking about
uh keital and like how kaido will be an
ally eventually but they
they're worried about callus and like
they got they were like we need to talk
about callus
and the thing we found on the glycon
like
so they're not apparently just like kind
of ditching that forever that appears to
be
something they may return to and i this
sounded like mara herself was very
interested in that and in callus so
i don't think we have seen um the last
of that whole situation either yeah was
it in this oh i was gonna say was it in
like the storyboard cinematic where i
say those because like the inkblot ones
whatever you want to call them was that
where we saw kind of the look of the
director with again still the darkness
like the little twirls and stuff and we
saw something like that recently like
that same image at the end of season of
arrivals i saw that somewhere recently
again and i was like so they're not
leaving it alone but also on the other
side
i was like they haven't touched it
either so again i want to see what they
do more with the darkness so as you said
with well they settled not attacking us
on purpose like they have some sort of
greater purpose here right the thing
that the thing that strikes me is that
like this year this year of savathune
they have to sort of finish off the
whole hive story because we sort of
already have an ending to the cabal and
even the fallen right like we know where
those stories are ending right the vex i
don't know if they'll ever come up with
an ending for that but this next year
sort of has to end the hive story
because we know the next two years of
destiny are probably going to be
darkness whatever the heck that is and
they're going to be focused on the
whatever the greater threat is based on
the name light fall and and the final
shape uh so i i'm wondering if this is
like they what what loose ends do they
have to tie up with the with the hive
like i to me paul you mentioned zebra
wrath earlier i don't see him coming
into like the limelight
what's that i'm sorry
sorry i forgot the the hive uh changed
your genders all the time uh the
uh um
i i don't i don't see her coming into
the limelight because
to me it's like you know daredevil and
the marvel like they'll give her her own
show but you know she's never shown up
in civil war you know what i mean like i
don't i don't think that she's ever
gonna show up in the in the witch queen
story or anything like that i think we
might kill her during the season
actually or during during the extra long
you know 30th anniversary thing or
something like that just because we've
not seen her mentioned really in any of
the main
content she's always i mean she's always
in the background like that's the thing
is yeah oh it's zebra forces doing this
and doing that and like right now right
now kaido is fighting zebra wrath that's
what kail's doing like they're having
like space battles
and then
was the one to take osiris's light yep
uh zebra wrath is the one hunting
sabbath which is why seventh year is
like hiding it's just that like
i i i would be surprised if we never had
a direct confrontation with zebra rat i
guess it's it is a little weird because
it is one character
that is kind of so omnipresent and yet
not seen at all yeah you never hear
directly from zebra wrath even really
yeah i can't even think of lore books
there might be some but
i i have not heard from zebra wrath
really in any way so i mean that may
change but like i don't want another
year building up zebra harassment yeah
yeah for sure no way yeah so like i
would be amazed if we didn't if this
didn't come to a head either as you say
at some point in the six month season or
in the witch queen yeah any time if it's
delayed beyond that i'm like okay this
has been a bit too long i think
yeah it's gonna say maybe maybe it'll
maybe it'll be someone that uh sabathune
kills as soon as she gets the light
it'll just be like a show of force like
oh she kills zebra wrath and like the
opening cut scene of of the witch queen
or something just not a piece of [ __ ]
i know some people would be mad about
not getting to fight though oh for sure
maybe a dungeon boss if we align
ourselves with sabathune maybe the
dungeon is they are doing a lot more
dungeons now yeah we're gonna have three
over the next like
16 months which is going to be
absolutely crazy yeah it is weird though
because by the way shout out to biff and
i know they're working on this big like
lore project did you guys see the
concept video he did for the stuff that
they're working on did you see the
concept they did for zebra wrath yeah
yeah both of those things are good yeah
please let me find that zebra or wrath
because like the god of war it just
looks like an absolute
just beast out there in the hive and
then sabbath felt so bad for them but
they they did they did this awesome
sabbath art and then punching one
revealed sabbath
promotion for this season wasn't it like
a day later like they both look good
they're just very different yeah
absolutely yeah it's interesting because
um like to travis's point with with the
hive it feels like you know one of those
little pieces where we find out that um
zebra rat that took osiris is like we
also find out that a lot of these hive
soldiers
are are now pledging their fealty to
zebra and they they feel disrespected by
savithoon that you know first osiris
went in there and killed crota's kids or
whatever it is before he got caught out
there and then just her actions and i
guess portraying the whole worm and sore
logic stuff so that that part's
interesting i i definitely wouldn't go
back with with martha there was some
interesting stuff i don't know if you
caught this paul where
she was a co i forgot what i read it and
it was a conversation with her and petra
and it was more along the lines like
i have a real master plan for what to do
with crowell
instead of this thing that he has been
exhumed to become
and
i thought that was chilling like she
still has a little side things that
she's weaving behind the scenes yeah she
wanted him to like get the light but to
still be aldrin that was it right yeah
no but there's a i'm trying to remember
i know what that's the main conversation
that you go up into the um
the thing next to the uh the seasonal
content but i believe it's a lore piece
that i read or something to that effect
where she is talking to petra and the
effect is like i have a master plan to
kind of now look like she's got to
reverse this process but like to
bring back the older and she knows not
this she looks at him as this detestable
thing
as a guardian she does not look at him
the same and she still has ultimate plan
and then she even gives a safeguard to
petra to say something to the fact well
if it doesn't go right we got measures
for that like if he doesn't take to
whatever this
transformation back to uldred is you
gotta you gotta catch up maybe new
resident he's a big lord guy but i
forgot where i just read it this week i
was like right now i know exactly you're
talking about it i i i saw that too um
yeah so it's interesting because it
creates this real dichotomy where like
mara is his literal sister and yet her
plan her plan for aldrin was always just
to kind of have aldrin become a guardian
someday
and which involves him dying first of
all like obviously so she was willing to
sacrifice that so she could have a
guardian that she that was under her
controller but she didn't have to die
and now so that's crow and she hates
crow because he's not her brother so
she's just trying to pull aldrin kind of
back out again whereas you have in
contrast you have sabbath in and like
seven clearly was tricking crow the
whole time as osiris and yet if you read
like the sabbath lore the hawkmoon lore
especially
by the campfire where she's osiris and
she's like feeling like warm fuzzy
feelings of like actually
liking us and crow like i think
saboteur probably has a better
relationship with crow and maybe
genuinely like crow yeah than more
healthier or yeah because like
maybe saboteur does have some secret
plan for it for crow but
i also think she might actually just
kind of like him kind of like oh yeah
want to be friends with him i i don't
know i'm sure he's like this guy's not
so bad i would trust him with you with
crow more than i would trust with crow
with this egg for sure crow is
persistent like he still wants this
audience he wants to engage it's almost
like this father slash mother figure
that he had when she was imitating
osiris and it was it's like a you know a
betrayal but i i kind of i have
questions i need to know kind of thing
whereas everyone else is like look
you're talking to the witch queen the
queen of deception you are going to get
manipulated yeah what do you think
i i will say the one thing that doesn't
work for me this season with this whole
thing we're talking about is is the fact
that crow still doesn't know who he was
or what he did that yeah
this has gone too long now it doesn't
even make sense that he couldn't have
found out on his own at this point like
right aldrin killing kate is like a
historical event yes everyone would know
that and everyone would be talking about
it like he could have there are a
million ways he could have found out on
his own
one of the random workers in the house
yeah exactly like we we should have told
him as his friend at this point like i
it doesn't really make sense to me that
we have been keeping it secret
for this long when like and even the end
result of this is like
so like so yeah that was a difficult
dude i'm not right dude and like yeah
you know he might be coming back like we
don't know who we were before we were
guardians like we don't question who
right you know zavala or cora were like
as people before they were you know
risen like
this plot point doesn't really quite sit
right with me and like i wonder how
they're going to handle it when it
finally is revealed which which could be
the end of the storyline maybe sabathin
tells him but yeah
it's just
no i agree i agree i think it's it's
it's weird they're almost throwing it in
our face jokingly because like everyone
knows but him and it's just like yeah so
to me the only thing i can think of is
they do have some
big reveal moment you know to try to
encapsulate this for him as a character
because it really makes no sense as to
why he has just not been told straight
or maybe it's savithoon you know herself
that does i don't know it's interesting
why they're holding on to this for so
long i agree with you paul like it's
very weird that this just is dragged on
so long because it's forbidden to look
into your past guys come on follow the
rules
yes
yeah i'm glad they didn't drag out the
osiris thing for another six months
because like at that point that got so
obvious where i'm like yeah they have to
just like reveal it now yeah that was
like kind of perfect timing for it yep
at the beginning of the season but the
whole the whole crow thing is just it's
literally been you know it's we're
approaching a full year now at this
point like it
it's it's time agreed agreed
well
it's been a lot of fun so far exploring
the story shattered realm astral
alignment when it works as you said and
the lures i still am so intrigued with
the lord just to know that we know where
we're heading in which queen we have so
many months to get there and we know
we've got what this is week five so we
have five more weeks basically
potentially of story beats ish if they
go that long with it i don't know if
they're going to do an epilogue i don't
know if it'll it'll be three based on
the quest steps oh yeah because what
seven is the
quest for the radio messages yeah
but then it's like i don't know if
they're gonna if they had an epilogue
planned if the 30th like is there's this
like kind of go-between story i don't
really know but honestly it will say
like everything you guys are saying it's
like if you've ever enjoyed the lore at
all and you haven't paid too much
attention find some way to catch up on
it because the story is actually in a
really fantastic place right now
absolutely really is absolutely doing a
great job something that isn't in a
fantastic place right now or at least
it's very debatable and that's trials
it's in a fantastic place what are you
talking about fantastic it's great it's
like is it a lot of people serious
that's awesome
so the first two weeks have been what
seem like bungie for one some people
saying hey they're renewed pvp focus
they're talking about it every single
week so if nothing else we gotta give
them credit that finally took a little
while to get there they are talking
about crucible they're messing with
crucible crucible labs is coming back
which is going to be trials labs um but
i wanted to get your guys take on the
past weekend with matchmaking for those
of you guys that don't know
matchmaking this past weekend
was adjusted because it changed where
when you became
you had a flawless card you were now in
a flawless matchmaking pool separate
from anybody who had not gone flawless
so even if you reset your card started
over at zero wins you were still match
me you were in a flawless pool
so
who played who had a good time who
didn't let's let's hear it i'm curious
you go first because okay okay yeah you
said you went to lawless for the first
time he got killed yeah
yeah i got flaws for the first time i've
never been flawless in d2 i wouldn't be
remiss if i shout out to homie dj orals
from the clan that's my guy he was like
cog if you don't hurry up and get
flawless with us he was like the whole
clan's gonna be flawless except you and
i was just joking but all jokes aside
like yeah we did we did it late
obviously on monday i believe so at that
point i don't know what the q situation
was at that point with the flawless
stuff but
yeah it was it was really fun it was
really fun you probably you know first
three to four matches honestly were
stomps we we we were killing you know
killing stuff i was i was literally
doing my thing there's no doubt once we
got yeah round right match six or seven
it got a little it got a little spooky
it got definitely got more intense and
um yeah we were able to pull it out
first time at the lighthouse you know
got me a reed's regret didn't get the
guard roll but they say people are
telling me my triple threat firing line
will eventually be better once it's got
a triple tap firing line that's that's a
pretty damn good idea yeah that's okay
that's very good i mean
right now but
that's like that's
the second best roll
yeah that's one of the two god rolls
yeah that's like one of the two that you
want yeah it was cool man like i've
never been flawless so i was like why is
my weapon change color like it was so
many things i didn't know i was like
this was a whole new world to me it was
it's like being in the vip section of
the club
yeah i was like wow y'all have drinks
like this and food like shopping at a
whole foods for the first time after uh
oh my god bro this was like being vip i
got to see what the life travis was
living all this time that i was a part
of it now you know what i said so it
just felt good you know to be brought up
into his world but
this metaphor is travis the bouncer who
doesn't like it like he wasn't nobody
never been what i've said never been
what i've said ever
you guys keep casting that on me i've
never said i want fewer people to go to
the white house i've never said i have
my elitist coupon i was ready i said hey
i could get in i'll be just trying
i'm teasing i'm on tv
look it felt good uh you know it's never
happened before the loot was great you
know regrinding was great you know
utilizing the secondary um
what is it the the other you know trying
to win again once you've made it to try
to farm adapts probably got smashed very
quickly like in the second one so we
were definitely in that pool and i felt
the effects immediately so you know look
it's debatable i i'll let you guys talk
about you know what what's right or
wrong but my overall experience i was
happy man it was something and shout out
to king he got you know follow us again
more people are playing i just i like to
see the pool where it's at but i
definitely understand we still have work
to do we're still not in this nirvana
state of everything but my experience
was positive so i'm curious about the
great debaters here how they feel how
they're how their weak win how they
experience win round one fight no
who wants to go first oh god okay so
this weekend was
i i would say even more all over play
all over the place in the first weekend
so when i first started on friday right
away
it was like it it was better than it was
previously i
you know some people got out of the
flawless pool right or some got into the
falls pool right away it was bugged then
they turned on later that night so by
that night
i think i was like at like i don't know
60 win rate or something which is a lot
higher than i would normally be
and it felt it felt better and then the
next day
i played like i think late saturday and
by that point even more people had
cleared out of the pool so i kept
getting into games where it was like
mostly randoms versus randoms but like
all of us were so bad it was like a coin
flip in terms of
like how a game would go because you'd
see the other team there's no like
gilded flawless people there and
everyone's using like random loadouts
and you're like okay we got this and
then you look at your team and they have
somehow even worse slow downs and you're
like oh my god and so it's just it's
like a total
you know
it's like all over the place
and so like some of those games were fun
but then some of those where it's like
i'm not good enough to carry two people
so if they're bad enough i'm gonna lose
then sunday i teamed up with some some
actual readers okay and i played with
these two guys from sweden who
probably the best people i've ever
played with
they were they are phenomenal so
they took me flawless i actually did
okay like i wasn't being totally carried
or anything i was doing all right um and
but that was in the flawless pool they
had already gone flawless so oh never
stack three stack
other stack three stacks the whole time
so
it was very intense it was it was sort
of like old-school trials but okay uh we
did i think we lost our first card but
we sweeped it out in the second one okay
and a couple games after that so like i
i ran the full spectrum uh and i guess
so i know travis is like he has this
debate so like i know your argument
before was like
last weekend it was just too easy to get
flawless it was too easy to carry people
to flawless multiple times because like
there was no flawless pool any of that
in theory isn't the flawless pool kind
of like
what you were asking for like because
wouldn't it
once you're there doesn't that kind of
retain the challenge
of trials isn't that like one of the
things that you were kind of wanting the
most is for being flawless to mean
something so at least after the first
time you get flawless
after that it's it's a real challenge in
that pool so like
did you have an issue with that or i'm
just curious what you thought of this
weekend given how different it was yeah
a few things uh one the flawless pool
appeared to not be working pretty much
the whole weekend so i played quite a
bit of trials and
uh while i was still on my first card
before we went flawless and this was
late it was like on sunday that i played
um
i i we were going up against people that
had already been flawless that weekend
so
i don't know what the matchmaking rules
are but that that wasn't working and
then on the other end when we were
flawless we were also going up against
people who had not gone flawless so i'm
not 100 convinced that it was working
100 percent it's not the other thing is
that like they said yeah they would try
to do it so like
it was i would say i would say it was
like 40 of the time we were surprised
either side of the phone like it was
like more more than i would have thought
uh the other thing is that because
you've already gone flawless you it sort
of takes the tournament out of the game
which was kind of one of the things so
let me just get some like the crux of my
issue because obviously i i said a long
time ago that if they ever added
matchmaking to trials that it would
cease to be trials and that to me i
thought was was bad the reason i think
that that's bad isn't because i want
fewer people to go to the lighthouse or
for going to the lighthouse to mean
something i really don't care about that
i just want
i want there to be an end game activity
for pvp players who are interested in
improving and playing against other
sweaty people and there's currently no
mode in the game to do that trials has
aspired to be that in the past and
sometimes it's gotten close it's never
really fully realized it but them adding
matchmaking is them saying okay we're no
longer going to even shoot for that as a
goal we're going to go the other way and
we're going to try to make it where it's
more accessible and then that means that
there is no end game activity for people
in pvp and currently there is no end
game activity for pvp players there just
isn't and so that that is my problem is
that i want there to be an endgame pvp
activity in in destiny and
right now there
there's a very big void there and i
don't i don't know that they have a
they definitely don't have a solution
for it but i don't know if they have an
interest in adding something like that
in the future and so them adding
matchmaking to me was them giving up on
that idea that there should be an end
game activity for pvp players who are
looking to play against their peers and
level up in in the crucible but isn't it
isn't a flawless only playlist even
harder than than that trials was before
kind of because no no no no it's not
i i i know you said you were matching
against people who weren't flawless but
like at least in theory if if it works
as it's supposed to
shouldn't that be
better because like you're mostly good
if running into like 50 stacks there
if 50 of the player base is going
flawless every weekend then not really
like the the previous situation with
trials was more competitive because the
player base was low and the people there
were really sweaty now the player base
is so big you're playing against people
who've gone flawless who you know maybe
aren't the best players and there's no
there's no rank system what we need and
we've talked about this with other pvp
people on the show is we need comp to
actually go back to trying to be a
ranked playlist rather than a a wheel
that you kind of grind yourself through
and then you start over at the beginning
it needs to you know like rocket league
where there's a diamond tier and there's
a
gold tier and you kind of work your way
up the ranks and you play against your
peers and you try to improve there's
nothing like that in destiny right now
and trials was the closest thing we had
to it because of the tournament style
bracket and i i i don't think that the
solution of saying okay we're going to
make this mode more casual but then
there's going to be a separate playlist
for people who've succeeded because the
the bar for succeeding is also low so
there's just as my experience was that i
never really was in any danger of losing
we didn't use our mercy we we didn't
lose any matches it was just sort of
like we weren't even really
communicating if i'm being honest i feel
like there was something there though
like there were even there were some
teams like it is still hard
are you playing on pc
are you playing on pc
no so i'm not playing on pc so maybe
that's the difference i don't know but
yeah i don't i'm not really sure but
yeah the the the
just basically my experience was that it
felt like a casual kind of like play
with your friends and get some wins and
get some loot which by the just to be
clear i'm okay with that existing in
destiny and i'm okay with that mode
being trials like if people want to go
to the lighthouse i'm not like oh we
should have exclusive loot or whatever
but i think it would be cool if i got
like a little icon that just said i was
in diamond rank or if i got a different
skin of a weapon that let me change my
weapon into a different color or gave me
a glow something like that that showed
that i was part of that community and
gave me even a cosmetic reward for that
sort of thing but it's just that there
isn't that in destiny and and
matchmaking and all the changes if you
read the twab all of their goals are
basically about like making it more
accessible
fine if they want to do that but they've
already got so many modes that are like
that iron banner is accessible pvp mode
comp is at this point of accessible pvp
mode because of the changes they've made
to the solo playlist and all that stuff
there is no end game pvp mode and i
wanted trials to be that and it's not so
i i just need something else i like i
agree with your idea about turning comp
into a true ranked playlist i i i think
not enough games have true ranked
playlists and destiny's really never
even done that too yeah old trials
wasn't really a true
it was the closest we got yeah
an old school halo system with actual
rank i think that would
be beneficial in destiny uh i just yeah
you know i i don't see a reason for them
not to do that this is one thing i've
always thought about trials where it's
like i think the fundamental structure
of trials is just
not really designed to be what you want
it to be that's what i've been telling
this boy
hey hey hey hey but to be to be clear
[ __ ] you keep telling me trials has
never been that thing you want it to be
no guess what else it is who wanted it
to be yeah that's what i'm saying it's
never been what i want it to be but
here's the other flip side of that
argument it's also never been what you
want no it is it is i love it how it is
now it is the thing no i love it
you love it now yeah absolutely
but it's also never been that until
recently guess what you can change
things
they just did it
i could flip the same way because when
you were happy when you were playing
against this low population where was
sweat on versus i was never happy also
what have i ever been like trials isn't
a great statement
i'm just going to take it here's the
thing here's the thing
the the trials state was in a middle
ground between being an endgame activity
and being a casual activity it was no
big deal i would say i would say i would
say it was closer
it was dead
it is dead versus thriving and now you
can tweak you you you you're you're
misinterpreting that what we were
playing prior to this season was some
active great mode it was not no i'm not
saying that i'm saying it was bad i have
all right i have always said trials is
broken and i would rather have them made
these changes than done nothing right
100 percent but my point is they could
have fixed it by going more hardcore and
making them shorting and doing part
matchmaking
included has now tarnished your great
legacy it's just you you're not yet
you're great you're you're in this one
percentile you don't represent the whole
group of people the majority of people
are actually challenged and having that
experience that you want you are in this
small percentile because of your
greatness that is not bungie's fault
that you are that great that you are
smashing everyone okay
my point my point is my point is it was
broken they could have fixed it by
curating the experience and making it
more endgame focused or they could have
made it more casual they chose casual i
wish that they would have doubled down
and tried to dedicate it because there
are ways cog we can at least agree that
there's a way for a a more sweaty pvp
activity to exist and definitely
successful of course
better for like
70 to 80 of the players whereas if they
went your way it would have made it
better for like you the ten percent of
them
you guys you guys are making a lot you
guys you guys are making a lot of
assumptions on that you're like
fear-mongering again because no
that's not true to a group of people but
it would have been that is not
necessarily true
my problem is give this man some extra
glows and this is over
okay so here's how it glow and an emblem
and a parade with roses
talk about trials when you when you go
there more than once all right
see the elitist is coming out this is
what i want i'm just saying i'm just
saying
i spent a lot of time with this mode is
what i'm saying so here's here's here's
how they could have done it guys they
could have implement if they wanted to
go the other way which i'm not saying
that they needed to or whatever i'm okay
with them doing comp i just want the
mode to exist that's all i'm telling you
guys it exists i want there to be a
competitive mode so what they could have
done is they could have implemented a
rank-based system in trials that means
that the people who are sweaty to the
sweating get matched with the sweatiest
of the sweating they get to keep their
one percent mode and then the people
that are like paul they get to play
against people in their bracket we agree
that exists in games so my point is if
they could have made a mode like that
made it more competitive not dropped to
the player base not made it exclusive to
the one percent there was a competitive
solution they chose not to do that so of
course i'm going to be disappointed as
somebody who does not have that in the
game now i just want to see how it was a
possibility because like listen you're
talking about you're talking about a
mode for you in a mode for me but i feel
like that exists the mode for me right
now when i'm not being carried is me
just kind of farming for wins casually
going seven and 20 on a card and yet
getting a bunch of engrams and like it's
fine i got way more last weekend the
weekend before this i got more loot that
weekend than i've ever gotten in like
all my trials things combined but i
don't think that's bad by the way
i think they should do
flawless and you have flawless cardboard
there is no more rewarding activity in
the game than being able to go
like 10 11 12 13 14 15 wins on a
flawless card because you were getting
ascendant char drops you're getting a
depth drops you're this is the most
loot endgame pvp people have ever had
and you were rewarded for being the best
of the best like i don't know if the
matchmaking is is perfect yet and you
still might be running into easy games
occasionally like i ran into a couple
really easy games on a post follows card
which seemed weird but like i feel like
the end game farm is there and is
rewarding for the best of the best
players in a way that i've never seen in
pvp not in any mode of trials
you're right on the rewarding part they
could have added the rewarding part
without changing trials and adding match
making all that stuff though i think all
the changes they made to trials except
for matchmaking helped cross play making
it more rewarding uh letting people play
on a card that had more than three
losses all that stuff is amazing and i
would have been like 100 if they added
that but
the
the i'm not worried about how rewarding
it is personally i just want to be able
to play against my peers and feel like
i'm improving and playing in my bracket
and that sort of stuff and so i'm not
okay so
how much loot per hour am i getting i'm
looking at it from like am i playing
competitive matches and my answer right
now is absolutely not every match i play
is like all right this is hilarious like
it's just you know it's not the same
speaks to your greatness
i just i just want to be able to play
against the people that
that are at that level
there just needs to be a rank system
you're good no it's fine i was letting
you guys trying to get all the pieces
out to try and figure out where it's at
travis i think what you want is a rework
of comp
more than anything else i think that is
going to serve you the best because
you're looking only because i've been
pushed out of trials you know what i
mean like
they could have done a rework of
it used to be the mode for guys like me
and now it's like well travis there's
this other mode that we made called just
this mode like you know what i mean but
travis let me ask you this question you
want more people playing trials
yes no
correct
okay and yet you don't want
matchmaking i don't i don't care about i
mean i think matchmaking would be
okay if there was ranked playlist
but there isn't
if there were skill-based matchmaking
comp systems in trials then 100
which i actually agree with him i
wouldn't be opposed if they were well
here's the thing the comp system is not
what i want in trials because the comp
system is terrible it is not but it's
not similar similar idea it but just it
just wasn't in effect it wasn't properly
implemented right i don't want it to be
like uh you grind and then you prestige
and reset your rank i want it to be
seasonal everybody's at bronze three and
then you're going up the rockets
you just beat your head against the wall
against something that this game has
just never really been and i'm just like
just because they've never done it
successfully doesn't mean they never
will and i think it's there's people
like me who want it in destiny and it's
our responsibility to be like this is
missing can you please advocate for it
right like i'm not saying it's ever
gonna happen dude destiny has never been
a balanced game and they've never had a
true endgame pvp mode it's not like i'm
like oh yeah this is this deserves to be
in destiny i'm entitled no i'm just
saying i need to speak my you know i
just look like
you're like you're i think you're like
the minority of the minority because
like yeah like he's in this even
players seem to be
embracing this to a certain extent like
i mean i i don't know who the like
literal top 100 right destiny players in
the world but like you know the sweaty
streamers who are always
i'm not that good at dpp just full
transparency all i'm say every time we
have a pvp guy on this show paul yeah
they say like yeah we need a ranked
system because there's no competitive
end game they say that every time
is anti what the changes just made
correct as you are i would probably i'm
not anti
he has said that he prefers the current
system unless a misunderstanding
corresponds to what it was before
correct posted
out of
he this man said they could have done
everything it would have been fine but
as soon as they get i think that's
tracking on that was when they lost him
don't let him get out of here we got to
hold his feet to the fire it's the
matchmaking
understands your
hatred of matchmaking like you don't
know that i'm wrong because they never
tried it my way my point is if they had
done all those first changes and then
held off matchmaking for like a month we
would have a lot more
of data players that are playing now
because people are not gonna we don't
know that's gonna play we don't know
that they're not i know people are not
gonna like the play
this is the mantra i've been saying for
years it was like the single biggest
are all three of you guys also for
matchmaking and raids just to be clear
no
no okay then [ __ ] you it's my answer
it's apples
i understand communicating with people
would be better in doing that but like
read mechanics thank you it does not
blend itself this is the most fallacious
argument if if your one concern is
increasing the player base we'd have 20
percent it's better to have 60 than 20
then we could increase the rate playlist
by 60 percent
so let's do it so
it is a worse experience if you're
talking to three people and they're all
people are going solo flawless for the
first time ever and being happy
but paul you got you guys all make the
same argument to me travis if you don't
like trials and with matchmaking then
just come in with a full crew well if
you don't like matchmaking and raid then
just come in with a full crew and raid
why not just add matchmaking for the
people who want it how does it hurt your
experience it doesn't hurt my experience
i'm just okay
then add it cause i'm right
we can all watch a rick cackas video and
figure out how to get through the grade
and know myself
like the whole 15 minutes like plays
yeah before your raid that would
actually be so yeah just watch
the thing
what
what is pvp
there are many ways to get trained for
pvp do you shoot the other bat do you
shoot the the red guy yeah
you shoot the red guy shoot the
objective see something kill it
your pv is showing
your pvp is showing because to me you're
going to say that no pvp requires
communication
work and strategy however if you're if
you're in matchmade trials and you are
in theory a team of three randoms versus
another team of three randoms none of
you are communicating you still know how
to play pvp
that's not the situation
because you're all on the same playing
field whereas that is not true on a raid
because you're working against the ai
and you have it right
you are you are 100 correct that it is
possible but it is without a doubt a
worse experience if you cannot talk to
your teammates and i would just say it's
the same of raids it is a worse version
of the experience so my point is if a
worse version can can exist for the
people who want it it's not forced why
can't you do that with rage that's not
this is this is the this is the double
standard
because i have three i have three pve
players telling me how a pvp road should
be wrong
because of matchmaking over simplifying
unplayable no okay hold on but couldn't
you say this one over simplification
like yes like you should there should be
no randomized matchmaking in any pvp
game because
it is a markedly better experience when
you can communicate with your teammates
one hundred percent okay so you can take
something like in every mode is a better
experience if you're playing with
friends and teammates it doesn't mean
that doesn't mean matchmaking why can't
the worst version exist in raid if it i
i know okay
teamwork and like exact
literal call-outs like audio call-outs
that are 100 percent necessary for the
most part unless you come up with from
some crazy work around like that is why
it's in its own category and why
everything except like you can you know
everything except that has it like that
is the reason
and so here's the difference between i
get what you're saying
yeah yeah
yeah so we gotta let you talk and then
we get travis we get right back
[Music]
yeah no so what i want to say is like
you take pve versus pvp one you have six
people trying to work together versus
three or four you also have a potential
one to two hour mode versus a five hour
mode so you have a larger time
commitment you also have a lot more
mechanics as paul is saying you have to
figure out what do i have to do here you
have six people that run to the start of
vault of glass
no what if they haven't been there
before they don't know they need to
stand on the plates to find this thing
what if they get off they do this thing
what do you do in pvp in every pvp game
you've ever done you can do apex
three-player high-level crazy stuff what
do you the only thing i wish they would
add is ping system but that's a
different story but like what do you
need in in pvp shoot the people over
there
now am i saying no travis
give me the rules
is
i'm talking to three people who are
never going to see my point of view
because they just don't understand no no
like that's fine
when you play with high level people
like paul played with those two people
and he's probably like these people are
working on a different level like the a
couple times i've played with like
people who are working on a different
level i've seen that work and it's like
that is astounding level of skill but
again what are they still doing they're
communicating to make that shooting the
other person more efficient and they're
much much much much much better at it
than the average skilled person is going
to be in matchmaking check i get there's
a huge disparity in skill but what do
you have to do you still just have to
kill the other person when it comes to a
raid
when it comes to matchmaking and this is
where it's like i've understood bungie
for a very long time when you go into
matchmaking in a raid
you have to understand how to do the
mechanics like okay templar six people
who don't know what they're doing and
you go in it's like okay figure it out
they're likely never gonna figure that
out if they can't talk can you put six
people in a pvp match and have them
figure out what to do yeah make the
number go up on the scoreboard that's it
the general functionality in pvp is very
simple there are huge disparities in
skill level and i completely understand
that all i'm saying is matchmaking in
pvp
broadens the pool and that is bungie's
entire goal
they're trying to get more people in
this mode if we can ever get trying to
get more people in raids
i'm worried about the player base of
raids they're just such a low count you
know it's such a failed match
because a failed match made trials game
is like four minutes it's like if you're
in a bad team you can't communicate
everyone's doing their own thing and you
die that game is over in four minutes if
you try and do a match made raid and you
don't give up it'll probably take you
like 12 hours like to me that is the
difference in the design of the mode
also like in addition to the other stuff
we said i think time is a factor too
because it takes enough work to even get
six people together in a raid but like
if if that's a bad group it stays with
you for
infinitely longer than like okay we
match made for one bad trials game that
sucked let's do a new one
it's yeah yeah yeah on the match made
playlist
why don't wipe
then just don't play on the match made
raid playlist no but there's a there's a
difference of like what they're trying
to do now is they're trying to bring
more people into trials they're like hey
you can farm reputation i know what
they're trying to do guys like obviously
i get it my point is
that
you guys know my point i've never been
playing but the whole point is like for
one matchmaking and pvp very different
than pve you cannot say those are even
i'll die on that hill but the other side
is they're trying to get more people
into this mode and it's worked
and that's one of the reasons and i've
when have i ever said that's a bad thing
okay but if
going flawless but then that puts more
people
in the flawless pool which makes that
too easy so i'm just saying
i'm just saying it it adds complexity
that takes away from it being a an
endgame experience at this point i've
just given up on trials being the end
game pvp experience but then there needs
to be something that is it and i wanted
trials to be that mode because it seemed
like that's what they were trying to do
and they were in the spot where it just
wasn't working and they were like all
right we could try to go one way or the
other and they went the way that i don't
think they needed to go because there's
already a ton of pvp experiences that
are casual more casual and i don't know
if trials on its own represent something
that is unique or new from iron banner
or the comp playlist or all the other
stuff they have and now the thing that
they're missing
is
a competitive mode right now an end game
company maybe that is something maybe
that's something that they're working on
because remember the renewed focus like
three four casual modes that's not right
i guarantee you they are not working on
it which i don't think so travis that
they probably do need it and that would
be a good addition in addition to the
other stuff they've done but like
given what they've done with people like
we don't even have an iron banner loot
rework yet like they're not building a
competitive ranked playlist
i don't think so
unfortunately but
i don't know if it's the game for him
anymore because he's so passionate about
it and i'm just like
yeah i
so look i have plenty of other games i
can play for competitive experience and
i'm going to be playing one this weekend
halo infinite and that that will be
where i go when i want that you know
ultra sweaty experience
but i know but cog here's the thing the
thing about destiny and the reason we
love it as pvp guys is because we get to
take all of our achievements and bring
it to a place where we get to put them
to the test oh for sure
if there is no end game pvp guys then
people like me don't get that experience
we don't have a place we don't have a
place where we get to go and put
ourselves to the test because trials
just got casualified the comp playlist
has been pretty casual for a long time
now iron banner isn't really
you know he's got this basically tell me
how how big of a street can you get on
your flawless card this weekend let me
know right that's that's how i say it it
exists it's just not in the fashion you
want it it technically is what paul and
he is saying in the floor but it is
on a card
it should theoretically be matching you
with people that are like 15-0 20 you
know 25 and oh and a card and then you'd
be getting your hardest challenges
but it's clear matchmaking is not at
that level yet and you're just going to
get a lot of easy games mixed in there
too so maybe if they just keep doing it
and they can figure out matchmaking to a
better degree it'll get better but i do
understand why like
it it the matchmaking itself is not
necessarily where it needs to be if you
want like only challenging games but
then you would have even more people
complaining about that i guarantee you
even that are high skill because they
don't want every game necessarily to be
you know the most challenging sweat fest
ever so but they but they do want a
certain amount of the players on the low
end of the skill base to go flawless
they're trying to like work that
percentage and so that pool of flawless
players is always going to
be well a lot of those people it's not
if you're struggling to get flawless and
then you're dropped in the flawless pool
let me tell you you're not going to be
playing very much longer and like that's
kind of the whole debate from this week
is like yeah should that pool exist does
that build too many walls like that's a
whole other debate we haven't really
even gone into but yeah so i i don't
know i don't think it's getting like
deluded to the same degree i think for
every every player that goes flawless
once like
yeah you know you're probably
only a couple that that transition into
farming the flawless playlist solo
certainly i think you'll get a lot more
three stacks doing it but
it's a nightmare at least can we at
least admit that my claim on fire team
chat that if they added matchmaking to
trials it would fundamentally shift what
trials was trying to be and effectively
kill that mode
on on what it was trying to be it would
change the nature of it that was my
point when i said like the spirit of
trials will be gone there will be no end
game activity i think
obviously
extreme
i get what you're saying the mode is
more alive now but
like am i a good enough pvp player where
i should have a full set of trials armor
and a bunch of god will trials guns
maybe not like maybe maybe that should
have been kept for the most elite of
elite things and yet i don't even care
about that but but that's that's part of
it because a lot of pvp players maybe
that's not your complaint specifically
but a lot of high-end pvp players were
like we're not rewarded enough and we
don't want necessarily like people who
aren't skilled enough to be getting
these rewards that were supposed to be
reserved for us like that is an argument
so like that aspect of it has changed
and it is a lot easier to at least get
loot in the mode uh but like i would say
for 99 of the player base trials is
still what would be classified as a
quote end game challenge and like i get
that it may not be for you anymore or
feel that way but
i just don't think that's a widely
shared belief yeah it basically never
never uh was the right mode for me for
all of d2 i think d1 it showed potential
for being yeah in-game activity and i
had hoped that they would work and
develop it on being game activity but i
agree with you guys like it was broken
for so long they needed to change
something i just wanted them to go the
other way and
add a skill based system where they
could get more people in there without
taking away some of the stuff i thought
was core to trials and one of the things
i thought was the matchmaking stick
sticking with seven people the entire
way
if you add matchmaking you can't do that
you can't stick with the with your fire
team for seven matches
how did that work for you kind of yeah i
mean i was at the top of the leaderboard
i had somewhere i lost actually because
we went up against three stacks and you
just can't win but the thing that the
thing that disappointed me was that if
you're playing that mode you don't get a
sense of what trials is like the only
thing is that you've played it are
slightly different it's a period but you
don't you don't get you don't get the
the hey i'm going with this team all the
way to the lighthouse we're gonna win
seven games in a row that's just like
dead if you use any matchmaking because
it's i don't know if that's a different
team every night no it is i don't know
if it's definitely because i've had
scenarios i'll be honest i cannot speak
to this one i've actually played
matchmaking i played matchmaking
exclusively the first weekend
i've had scenarios where literally i'm
the best player about 60 to 70 of my
matches after those matches i got xbox
live messages saying hey bro would you
like to link you know good gg like i've
been getting ggs i've been getting that
kind of vibe and people want to play so
i'm not going to say never because i
think if you do have a good experience
with the with the randomness of
matchmaking you're going to want to
maybe possibly link up with some people
that can get you there that's all i'm
saying just my experience
yeah it is and i i i don't know if i
could do it to be honest just because
it's like you know
it takes out all the teamwork okay so
take that right there like if you're
saying shout out real quick to the liz
22 with the five dollar super chat the
liz
maybe creating something competitive for
which we make trials make trials quote
casual to get the player base up for now
for more feedback hence why they're
doing trials labs and i think that's
like whether you want to consider trials
that's one thing but i think them trying
to get more people playing the playlist
that they have is a good thing in
general and i think we all do agree that
more people in the playlist is a good
thing is the mode this hardcore thing
that you wanted it to be
it may not be what you're looking for
anymore it's also
the same mode it's also not the same
mode because you don't go with a fire
team for seven matches and climb the
hill together if you enter matchmaking
you're essentially not really getting
the trials experience but it's an option
set up a fire team you're doing
call-outs
you can't do it i know i know it's an
option but guys if i had the opportunity
for a match
i wouldn't get the same experience but
you can't finish that match
it's the experience is gone because you
can't when you literally can still match
up with two other people and you'll do
that experience so it's not of course
you gotta beat us
yeah exactly
but if you ask me what is like essential
to that mode i would say
being with a fire team for seven matches
getting seven wins together that sort of
stuff and that is gone if you play the
match made version just like the whole
concept of working together in a raid
would be gone if you played the
matchmaking experience which is why i
brought up that facetious argument right
like you guys know what a raid consists
of and i said hey i'm going to take away
this thing that's super core to it you
guys would be like wait that's not a
raid and what if i told you i was going
to be raised okay
it's called guided games and no one
plays it
yeah
you know why because the mechanics are
so complicated no one can do it so then
so then let's take out let's take out
the mechanics for the matchmade mode
there's no mechanics being taken care of
take out the mechanics from the raid of
the matchmade mode that's what i'm
saying right
you just go into there you go there you
go make it make it make it make it a
smaller little mini striking camera
actually we kind of like that
do that yeah why not like why not so
yeah yeah there you go
my point my point is if you're taking
away something that i think is core to
trials which is running with the team
for seven matches then i get to do that
when i imagine this hypothetical trial
or raid matchmaking right so in this
case the core thing i'm taking away from
you guys are the mechanics there's no
mechanics in raids anymore it's just
about killing things and then you shoot
the boss right all the mechanics are
gone so then you guys would say but
without mechanics it's not a raid and i
would go yeah i know that's how i feel
about trials
a solo queue and then a separate 3v3
with with that i think that would be
better i think that would be better but
again the solo queues they're not really
playing the same mode no they're not and
and it's gonna you're gonna see very low
flawless rates because again it's a lot
of luck if it's yeah well if it's if
it's all so low yeah i guess you're
right it probably will it's also there's
going to be luck involved
that's coin flip i mean you don't know
you know what you're gonna get you're
gonna get on your team and how much
you'll have to carry them or be carried
so but that also goes into them trying
not to divide this player base right now
that they just built up like me
personally as a solo player whenever
they do the solo labs like i'm very
curious to spend some time in there
where i know every single match is going
to be solo and it kind of felt that way
part of the way through the weekend i
played on monday and most of them were a
lot of solos maybe some twos and ones i
don't know if i played against one the
one time i did i got stomped but a lot
of them felt
you know like the solo match made
matches which is kind of what i was
going for so like they were kind of
getting there and granted isolating the
flawless and even when we get to the
twab god knows when that's going to be
um
that is something they're actually
looking to get rid of
5 30.
there's a 12. we got a general idea here
in the 12th tons of trial stuff in it
i was like we'll cover it a little bit
but still the big thing is trials i get
the well this is why i literally asked
you last week the sanctity of the of
trials and you said no but you turn
around and say you want trials to be
this one thing so yes you did complain
about the sanctity of trials being this
three person yeah but when people say
the sanctity of trials they say like oh
he's trying to be a sweat lord who wants
to pub stomp people and only the leader
of the league can go to the lighthouse
and that's not what i'm saying at all
when i say the spirit of truth not what
i said i'm talking about like the way
the mode's actually designed
you're just like the only people i've
ever heard say like i just want to play
the best people in texas
i do though
no i believe you it's like
most and the guy the guy we had on last
week he agreed with me not designing
modes around that because you were such
a small tiny person but paul what
wouldn't you like it is if you could
match only with people in your rank and
then slowly go up and down that ladder
and improve that's a range eventually
you write something again that could
come later on like in the middle of the
road
yeah
that's how
but because it's more of a crapshoot in
the way that tr uh all of crucible is
set up right now you're never really
playing against people that you're
designed that are going to be in that
like golden area of you to improve with
you're going to play against people who
far below your level people far above
and those are not instructive matches
those are just like they just make you
not want to play anymore right and if
you could play against the fight yeah an
instructive match in destiny
exactly right because it's so it's so
wild westy and i feel like trials is now
even more the wild west than it used to
be
i just i just want there to be a mode
where like i'm playing against my peers
and your playing gets your peers and you
get a chance to improve at your level
and your pace and i do on mine and
trials could have been that i'm not
saying it ever was but it got close in
d1 and they went to the point that it's
never gonna be there exactly and then
now it's very wild west like it's just
no i'm sorry
i i feel like i get i get miss like
represented for saying that like trials
you know had a certain
i don't i don't think you're happy
seeing these flawlesses though
i would keep it a buck i don't think
you're that happy with all these
flawlesses running around i actually do
not care dude
every time i see somebody go to the
lighthouse i'm like yeah people are
playing trials that's awesome but uh but
on the other hand i'm like but again are
you saying like did they go to the
lighthouse or you didn't even play
trials
i feel exactly the same way you would
feel if you saw somebody posting a photo
of them at the end of uh vault of glass
and they played the version with no
mechanics you would be like well you
didn't really like get to do all the fun
like standing on plates and going
through portals and then i would be like
well yeah i feel that way i love that i
feel the way i love it because because
false equivalency
my point is i would feel the same way
because to me part of trials is going
with the same team and improving with
goals and that sort of stuff and you're
not getting that if you if you're like
you're not getting that experience you
get whatever yeah because they're match
made they don't know what it is to stay
with a team if they're playing
exclusively that mode i get what you're
working on you're getting a worse
experience in matchmaking trials than if
you were on a fire team communicating
with people
yes but you would be getting a much
worse pretty much unplayable experience
if you are in a raid not communicating
with anyone like it would be unless they
took out much impossible to even
like function as a as a mode but if you
but if you can change what trials is in
order for matching you're not going to
exist on rules of trials you're not
changing the like you're just one of the
rules one of the rules was you have to
stick with the same team it would be
like changing trials to like a like a
like a lap race where you run circles
around the crucible course and there's
no gun play like i get what you're
saying obviously obviously i'm using the
holy cow of raids to get to it and they
are separate modes i realize that but my
point is if you can change the rules of
trials to make it fit matchmaking which
one of the rules was you stick with the
same team and you work with them then
you can change the rules of the raid so
i'm choosing to remove mechanics and
just make it basically a strike and then
people who post their photos with their
raid loot doing the strike versions you
kind of understand you're like it
doesn't hurt your experience but you're
also like i wonder if they got it out of
it the same thing that i got out of it
by going to trials like that's how i
feel about it like if you're like
frustrated
in trials it would almost be harder
oh for sure
that's the load right
there it's hard for the wrong reason
it's hard because the game mode is badly
designed if you play solo queue and so i
i don't think that that's like the same
thing like i want a well-designed
difficult experience rather than like a
one that's difficult because it's poorly
designed that's all we just made
i think i think he's doing push-ups
work it out you get your push-ups
i'm good
okay so i joked because i made a
thumbnail with these two going at it and
no you should have
against three this was a massacre it was
not a boxing match it was uh three
people jumping me in an alley
[Music]
yeah this is a 1v3 match
1v3 me bro
um
that comes out every week and we had
some words that they wrote about these
wonderful topics that we've been
discussing today so far so let's talk
about them let's get it
anyway
man that was that's just i can't even do
a clip i just have to be like go watch
the episode there's too much yeah i
missed thank you thank you guys for
doing that i know we get heated here but
i respect all of you guys
of course i feel pretty strongly about
this but at the end of the game yeah you
know it's a game and i like that they're
trying new stuff regardless like every
time i see that they're doing stuff in
trials in the twab i'm like hell yeah
like they're you know they're at least
paying any mind to it because this ever
since the relaunch it has been just a
horror show of like neglect
so i and i'm glad i'm not the dog locked
in the in the guitar or in the in the
car with the uh the windows rolled up
anymore uh that was that's what i felt
like for the past the show trial
terrible metaphor and also please don't
ever use the match made raid metaphor
ever ever again anyways moving on to the
club
so
this week
normal trials of assassin's creed list
is replaced by
trials labs capture zone this new mode
will still
have elimination but with the following
changes 30 seconds after the round
starts a capture zone is enabled players
can capture this zone to win the round
or just eliminate the other team capture
zone has a waypoint from the start so
you know where it's going to be
including a countdown timer so everyone
knows exactly when and where the capture
zone starts in the middle of the map
in the first round and changes locations
each round the team who lost that
previous round gets the advantage for
the spawn location for the next round
uh also for this week we got double
trials rank points so definitely spend
some time in there but what do you guys
think how does this capture zone sound
for trials it sounds like we're going to
go to we're going to get shatter dives
or there's going to be like five riffs
in the in the thing
is getting some of those raid mechanics
yeah
here you go i i i'm curious to try it my
guess is it me too probably doesn't work
as well as normal trials but
i actually think different game types
has been something that like pvp needs
for a long time and including trials
like i think they need but the problem
is
the the control thing like that's every
game mode like why would they choose
that one to beta test with trials i just
wish they would even the bomb planting
one i thought was more interesting
because it was an actual objective and
yeah whatever that game mode was or you
planted the bomb and promoted or disarm
it that was really cool so
um
yeah i i i'm excited to see where this
goes i like i said i'm glad that they're
trying new stuff
there's definitely cog
i'm like
i don't know if you can go to the
lighthouse and trials laps
i don't know how the ranking is going to
work is it going to count towards your
card is it just this like
because they did crucible labs before
and i don't even know if you got rewards
from it it's replacing trials they said
it's it's replacing them well this week
it is that's right yeah so it is real
trials and it's double xp you're double
right
you go to the lighthouse yes capture
zone is only the only trials mode this
week it's not a separate
mode it is replacing trials this week
yeah yeah
for better better so that's so
everything yeah they're going to get
their data about this unless you don't
feel like
yeah
it's going to be something different i
mean next week because it's iron banner
because i'm a man i like that they're
doing that i like that i like that yeah
i actually don't mind i think i think
they need to focus pvp playlists way
more often than they do now because like
you like iron banner every other week
and then trials and then they'd have
like a new you know you're shooting the
scorch cannons mode in the
casual playlist and just like yeah just
choose where you want your pvp people to
play and like point them to point to it
yeah it to me just seemed it reminds me
of like you know the d1 they try to make
a d1 iron banner equivalent when they
would be like okay this week's rift this
week's this this week's let you know
that's what it feels like and you know i
i i actually like the mode where it's at
so i just thought of refinement on the
mold but that's just me with trials
specifically i don't i don't mind it
with iron banner but you know hey i'll
give it a shot before i complain you
know and see how it is so we're gonna
have i will capture game types in a row
we're gonna have the trials capture the
zone and then we're gonna have iron
banner immediately after that we're
capturing zones right
at some point they'll get out of
next year we're gonna get a couple
different modes but for now it's all
variations on
control it seems like i will say an
objective
even for like this past weekend an
objective for that map would not be a
bad thing to force like people to move
around to play different areas
potentially go
you know if you start on c and you got
to go to point a for some reason you got
to play in that area instead of
everybody playing the damn little
cramped hallway over there yeah it would
it was like i think and it would depend
on the map too depending on where you're
forced to move around if it's a big one
if it's a small one i'll be curious what
the map is this weekend i actually hope
for labs they kind of do i would like to
see them do a couple maps because if
it's one map that kind of does or kind
of doesn't work you don't get to try out
more about the mode because the map will
kind of determine also like objective
working or not but as you guys have said
i'm sure there will be a fair amount of
shadow dives for the people hanging out
on the point for
everybody's going to be afraid to go
touch the point i can't without saying a
trials version of team scorched
i actually think trials rift would be
fun because i can't even imagine the
three person dunk the ball three
three people might be too small you'd
have to do it on small maps or something
yeah
it'd be kind of cool if you like
i don't know if you could dunk it but it
would be like
i know the king of hill sounds weird if
they moved it around the map but like
you pick something hold on to it and you
got to kind of defend the teammates and
then like oddball hold that
i sure yeah hot ball from halo where
they're holding it
yeah
i also thought they should do juggernaut
just like give somebody an infinite
super and then everybody has to try to
kill him and then whoever kills him gets
the infinite super you know what i mean
like oh almost like a zombie almost like
a zombie tagging mode like you know
it's like it's like the juggernaut mode
where like one person is super buff and
gets points whenever they kill somebody
as the juggernaut and then everybody's
goal is to kill them so that they can
become the juggernaut and start scoring
points like i think that would work in
uh in trials if you could find a way or
in comp if you could try to
trials would be ridiculous but it would
work
how would that even work three people
and just at all times
yeah
no i think it would work in a in like a
crucible but it would um yeah i don't i
mean they just they're i think they're
afraid you know they're doing something
and riff's coming back obviously my
guess is they're gonna do some sort of
swat mode just because that's
pretty easy to do i think and they
they're already almost there with
momentum control anyway twilight
garrison twice
we need it we need it for bringing rift
back that's key to my dave brought
almost everything else back from t1 yeah
at some point we'll probably get at some
point
could it be too ugly to be in the game
we will find out so ornaments you could
you could shade it in ornament yeah yeah
uh you couldn't explain
are you going are you flawless
so then one of the main changes we made
to trials this season was to allow solo
and duo players to queue up obviously we
just had that hour-long debate about
that uh had two main benefits it allowed
players a low barrier of entry and
expectation to try the mode out allows
them to try it
and then maybe they'll take it farther
travis but they try it be nice be nice
what have i ever said i'm against people
trying the most
for coming into this peacefully weapons
down
and more importantly
uh it increased the population enough
that fire teams of mid-skill players
landed more wins than if they matched
against other mid skill or high skilled
fire teams uh solar players are a key to
the entire system working for example in
our first week we had a whopping 54
percent or fire teams of solo duos duos
cut that to this team where 45 percent
were fire teams versus solo slash duo's
pretty sharp drop still
it's one out of every two game stills
randoms against the three stack i don't
know why it's
that is way too high in general i think
i don't know i don't know why they're
still bragging about that because that
that does not seem good one out of every
two games against a three stack is
almost an instant loss
i think the matchmaking it is the wild
west right now like that's just what
i've learned from playing and it's like
sometimes you get really good teams and
sometimes it's like geez and i'm sure
we'll get to this but they haven't fixed
that whole matchmaking manipulation
thing where they're making sure you
don't show up oh yeah
yeah showing the number yeah that you're
right absolutely they said oh yeah they
said they were going to pass that out
and they haven't they have not yeah and
they're not doing them for this week
either
no yeah that was i thought they were
working on it but i guess not yet
yeah okay keeping solar players playing
uh we learned a lot of the first from
the first two weeks of solo match making
week one solo wins there's 23 percent of
games blowouts 38 percent of games that
feels like it that almost is even low no
that felt low i got blown out so much in
the first week
uh
most worryingly the blowout rate for the
solo players went steadily up over the
weekend that yeah sounds about right but
then in the second weekend matchmaking
changes pushed that rate back down solo
wins were 36 so that went up 13 blowouts
went down nine percent so a little
change in both directions they're going
for said long term they're looking for
the solo win rate above 30
and solo fire team blowouts under 33
how does that sound for you guys for
goals of what they're trying to get to
for kind of a solo player
we want solo players to win maybe a
third of the time i don't know
this is why it's so hard to go flawless
solo because if you have a 1-3 shot of
winning a game and you have to do that
seven times seven imagine winning a coin
flip seven times in a row it's less than
a coin flip in fact so it's it's a third
so that that's why it's so hard to go
flawless when you're solo you have to
just get blind
they did say that they are not really
designing it for
solo queues they did they did say that
right
i always thought it would be like this
like it reminded me of the time where i
i won 15 games in a row to get reckless
i'm like the last day it was available
and like that was just so much luck like
i played okay but it was it was getting
good teammates so like you are going to
find instances where people go solo
flawless and they've never been flawless
before it's just it's going to be rare
and most of the time you're just going
to have people farming engrams or
whatever at lower tiers which is fine
that's all i did the first weekend
essentially
yeah and i think the mode is rewarding
enough now where even if you have no
expectation of going flawless it is
actually worthwhile to play that game
yeah and you know the adept weapons are
good but they're not so much better than
the regular versions that you just
wouldn't even try and i think that's
great it also helps flesh out the
playlist and get more people in there
and that sort of stuff but um i think uh
maybe that's okay if they only won 33 of
the time are you okay with that paul
like if you were a solo queuer
it doesn't feel good
and yet i don't i don't know if i can
like demand a 50
win rate
i
generally speaking i think
solo players go against three stacks too
often and because that that every time
that happens you just feel it's like a
90 chance you're gonna lose that and it
just it doesn't feel good at all yeah
like even regardless of if they're like
guild and flawless or whatever even if
they're just on a team that is enough to
beat a team of randoms most of the time
so one out of two games being that i
think that is still way too high and
that needs to come down it's good
i was just going to say i'm still
waiting for i want to see freelance yeah
i am very curious to see
versus what it tries absolutely i'm
trying that that to me is the key to
experiment because i agree both you guys
i think that
you know one-third is not something to
be bragging about you know per se and i
i think ultimately though they secretly
like that because i think they still
want to push towards the two or three
you know stack playing together so
i'm woody i i definitely think that i i
would love to see how the data pans out
with the freelance queue the same way
how we have in an iron banner and to see
what's the the ratio and percentages of
people getting matched up and going to
the lighthouse then that to me is
actually more useful data for the solo
guys i'm very curious one thing we're
not talking about is is twos so yeah i'm
talking about twos and chats playing as
a two felt actually pretty good i played
with one buddy of mine pretty frequently
and like we'd have a third that we
weren't talking to but
i you know i would say we were doing a
lot better than we would in a normal
in old trials under this system so like
twos is almost kind of a middle ground
that you're getting an advantage because
you're communicating with at least one
person
uh and so that can help you against more
three stacks but also it's not like full
solos full silence so i i think the twos
have benefited a lot from this yeah yeah
so you think there should be a freelance
playlist and two should be in the
playlist with threes
[Music]
well then then who's the third player
people who just don't know that's what i
was that's what i was going to say
that's like that's like the fruit of the
freelance playlist
um if they add it and separate it then
they can't have
you can't have a fire team
too
either someone who's so good they're
confident against the only three stacks
or it's so bad they don't know what
place they're going in in the first
place and they're just confused
so i see that comp already i mean
that already happens there so
that would be tricky yes
they do want to keep the game quality
high though they said we talk about
blowouts as one uh as looking for
competitive matches they also consider
five to one as not competitive they said
the sweet spot they're looking for is
five to two or five to four somewhere in
there we get a couple of rounds at least
somewhere to like the ultra sweat fast
four to five um they said in week one we
saw sixty percent of matches in either
five one or five zero that's pretty bad
in week two the number of
non-competitive dropped to 52 percent
that's still over half are basically
just blowouts which is
a small step in the right direction but
yeah 50 or stomps uh nice improvement
they said they'd like to see it down to
30 to 40 percent if all of like
i would say if
you know 60 70 of my matches were
at least a few rounds i won that would
feel better because it's the ones where
you don't win any or like maybe you get
a nice super and you get like cool like
a one but if you get at least a couple
rounds it feels at least a bit more
lively as opposed to stomp stomp stomp
stomp
to me yeah
you guys yeah i mean that's how old
trials felt to me where
on any point in the card at a certain
point when there was no
separation of rules or anything it was
just you could easily go 0 and 5 games
and games and games like if you if you
ran into a bad stretch and like i
haven't found as much of that in this
new version it still happens certainly
but i i would say it has proved
certainly from the old system
yeah i also don't want five and o's like
that's the other thing is if you're
eliminating o's and fives and ones and
fives you're also eliminating the
reverse because there's always another
team on the other side of it and i think
that's good for everyone if that happens
because i don't like matches where we
just destroyed it's like not interesting
it's not why i play trials it's not why
i play comp uh and i i think it's
healthier to make people hopefully play
against people that provide at least
some sort of meaningful challenge
yeah i mean i'm agree because we were
talking about that with the senate last
week is and as you were saying it's like
playing in your bracket that's why
everybody throws a fit about skill-based
matchmaking i'm like but that is going
to get you to a point where you play
against people around your wheelhouse of
skill and that's going to give you
matches where you can
if you want to some people are just
going to sit there twiddle their thumbs
and hope for some rewards but
if you go into the mode trying to
get a little better pay attention more
see if you can improve your skill maybe
you hit a few shots
if they're near your skill level you at
least have a shot to do that so
hopefully that's an improvement
uh they said other things that worked uh
we had just over 700 000 players this
weekend
over 50 000 players fewer than week one
this is higher than expected given a
normal drop off after launch combined
with the distant shore being a less
popular map plus we had 253 000 players
go flawless
games were 10 longer mostly due to more
competitive games they stayed
are those numbers that number sound high
to you that's like what not over a third
going
flawless that sounds those numbers so
good i think i mean i i'm surprised it
didn't drop more honestly with all the
controversy and there was a garbage map
for trials so like yeah yeah you know
that was actually kind of surprising to
me um which which is good news for the
mode and that people were sticking
around but
on the other side though things that
didn't work we saw 30 34
less matches played overall and the
number of matches post flawless dropped
by 45 percent not surprising
it was flawless was really weird though
like in week one it was like i i went
follow us that weekend and then
instantly i had like five games in a row
that were just jokes and were so easy
with my team like out of nowhere and
like it just
nothing about post seven made sense then
and then like on the other side when i
was playing solo on like a seven and
20 card or whatever
i was getting really really hard games
and like just getting crushed and i was
getting one reward every
five games or something so
it
just week one was really screwy uh in
terms of that so i'm not surprised if
they kind of fixed it to make it more
even that you would see a drop off like
that
yeah i mean
where are you falling on any of this
stuff yeah it's interesting i mean as
far as the uh the match played the post
flawless i think there was you know a
significant pushback you know for the
community obviously once the word came
out about the uh flawless pool and what
would happen and i think you know
players were utilizing methods to
circumvent those situations
so that that's what i saw and then i
wanted to comment on the thing before
that we didn't talk about i don't really
want to give him credit is i have to
admit like getting into matches were
pretty fast you know what i'm saying yes
which was really cool but we all
obviously we talked about we need to get
rid of that when you see the four like
we would smile like shout out to dd we
like oh you see that you know 5v6 if i
think they live searching for a third so
yeah they got to work on that i would
roll my eyes well i i wonder how much
that plays into
the one out of every two games against a
three stack if you can find randoms if
you could hide that system exactly i
wonder if they can drop it by another
ten percent just from that so it ain't
no shame in my game yo i was i was
smiling very very very widely with when
those things are going in my favor i've
never been flawless i did not care
i was like this is necessary bro i don't
know what's going to take this one
you know
when we get a free game because like the
other team didn't show up
that doesn't work anymore
that doesn't work
anymore yeah
yeah there was close to our um flawless
say on our sixth win one of the opposite
team that we faced
we we jumped out like you know 4-0 or
whatever you know about to crush them
and then like
that one of their guys
also like quit on them and i'm like damn
that's that that's really messed up i
still don't like the the penalties i
hope they address that as far as things
that doesn't work like the penalties i
think they initially said was like oh 30
minutes your timed out like it's got to
be harsher you can't abandon your team
and not have serious more serious
repercussions in my opinion i understand
timeouts disconnects happen so they
probably want to be careful of that but
the only reason i think that that might
be like risky is that some what if what
about the third guy whose two teammates
leave like does he have to sit there and
get killed for five rounds i mean it's
like three minutes i don't i don't know
why people are leaving at all because
you don't give a crap and i agreed yeah
i don't get it either it's i i don't
even know people understand how the rep
thing works now but there's really no
point in leaving if you're getting
crushed your game is going to be over in
like three minutes so like exactly yeah
it takes no time at all
cog i carried your uh your friend uh
lord addict yes
yes and uh
he uh i could hear the the giddiness in
his voice
this this childlike excitement when we
were in the uh the queue for the final
match and you saw the four
and then he saw the five and then he saw
the six and he's just he was like i'm
trying not to get excited right now guys
this is like listening i was like dude
we're gonna get you there regardless
for the majority of us mid average
you know players it it was it wasn't
getting it's a fear because it you feel
something's gonna go wrong it it's the
epitome of going from getting pub
stomped on
like card the win number two
and never getting past that to now
you're on the threshold of something
great and it's just pure getting and
they're getting gas i'm like no no dude
we got to focus you know we got to make
sure like don't get gas you don't say we
we actually one of the cars we actually
lost to a a match made team and i'm like
you see we got to use the mercy right
and now i'm really nervous like my
flawless is not going to happen now and
then we end up doing it so again
there's a huge percentage of players
that this is some unattainable thing
that there is pure excitement once they
get there and you know look it still
needs work obviously they you know
they're going there but i just wanted to
say that the heart was throbbing i was
happy that i saw yeah
and i'm happy that you're happy and got
to experience it contrary to what you
think about me for some reason i i i
truly forgot the fear travis what it's
like to fear the three stacks and and
flawless titles and
unbreakable dudes
when i'm on game six and seven i'm like
come on man this don't choke dude i
almost got beat by somebody who had like
a 0.2 kd i i think it was a it was a
recup but like i was just like am i
gonna
i'm gonna have to commit sepaku if i
lose this match like this is
unbelievable yeah because the opposite
feeling was like the most that's why i
said i want to see them still not give
up on the flawless pool thing because
the opposite feeling to me was always
you start trials you get that excitement
the hope right that you could go
round match one ratchet two you see a
dude with the flawless banner the adept
version of reeds i'm like this is my
first bat like what are you doing here
like like you get out of the child's
playground fam like i'm just trying to
start this and here you come bullying me
on the playground that's how that's one
way to deal with the majority of people
you know what you know what's one way to
do that is if there were ranks and
trials that you could play against your
peers
then then i would get to play with my
peers you get to play your peers and you
would both have similarly sweaty
experiences but at different levels
i'm just saying
it's something that
uh they had reports of significant
number of players resetting as you guys
kind of teased that the 50 and 60 cards
but we saw around 16 000 total cards
that were reset while flawless but under
seven wins given the vast number of
games and cards played 2.7 million cards
started this weekend that is why the
flawless pool idea doesn't work
because you can manipulate it but that's
the thing they said it's such a small
it's like a point something percentage
i don't know i just don't think that was
a widespread problem but having said
it's something they're watching and as
it's unhealthy for the mode if it
becomes more common it's something
they'll look at and they also state like
later on
they're looking to get rid of the
flawless pool so let me finish the rest
of this
yeah yeah normally normally we see
around 50 of the players who go flawless
do so with someone else who is already
flawless last week it was 56 percent
this can't be a traditional k this can
be their traditional carry or just
playing with friends that number dropped
to 16
this week which is unacceptably low for
friend game content that's my favorite
stat of the whole let's go
talk to him that's that's
this
yeah yeah because like i i can't
this happened so many times where like
people would just like okay have you got
follow us yet yes i can't play with you
like it's gonna be just a nightmare so
like that is the main problem with the
flawless pool that i mean i think there
their changes this week just doing the
flawless pool
only halfway through the weekend kind of
changes and that that can help with that
but
that was the most obvious thing i saw
happening this week was just the
inability
to play with your friends based on
whether or not you had gone followers
because once i went flawless i'm like
i'm done because like i can't play with
my normal group now who hasn't gone
flawless because that would just i know
that would be a nightmare so
that is not a good part of the system
and i understand why they're trying to
get rid of the flawless pool eventually
because that i think they should not
good
because to your point paul it was a
small percentage but there's also only a
very small percentage of people who feel
so confident in their abilities that
they're willing to reset a six or six
little six win ticket you know what i
mean so i don't know
like are they confident in their
abilities because isn't that the people
who just like want to pub stop people
isn't that no no no that would be people
who are doing carries but they don't
have carries yeah they want to carry
somebody else but then they get them you
know to that threshold and then they
they reset
okay they can they can get a random to
the lighthouse but not get themselves to
the lighthouse
well that's a weird yeah that's a weird
system so yeah that's yeah it is weird
but it means it means it makes it easier
for carriers because i'm keeping myself
in this you know pool of people who
haven't gone yet and then i can just
keep resetting my teammates
getting carried and have my guy
abandoned me on like game seven i don't
know i can help no they don't i just
reset my card that's reset i reset my
card and then i help you get there yeah
i didn't think so he's back at zero yeah
it's like it's like i i could just i
could just abuse the system and keep me
separate from the guys who i would
actually be afraid of and it just it
just allows you to manipulate the player
pool way too much yeah that's weird
that's not yeah like
people carrying okay you can't reset
your card if you you have never lost a
game or something right maybe you have
to complete yeah at some point then they
then they leave the then they leave the
player that they're trying to carry they
lose one match lose one and then they
hop back again with a fresh card there's
just no way to do it then fine
hey they said that about wind trading
and we all saw how that worked out if
you want to go through all that
literal wind trading so
yeah
uh so they didn't say they will wait
until sunday morning as you guys said to
enable the flawless pool so
much later i love how they're like
friday afternoon and i always forget
pacific is a couple hours back they're
like that's like friday night but either
way it's like
much later so they're doing two full
days until they actually get the
flawless pool active see what those
numbers look like they also said they
are turning off matchmaking and help
until you have played at least two
matches during the weekend what is
magical i guess
i mean
i think that's the one i think that last
week they described it as like if you
lose so many matches in a row when you
get stomped
and then finally it'll match you up
against someone i guess lower skill or
however they do that matchmaking there's
a pool of people who have lost five
matches in a row but if you only have to
play two games
yeah i don't know how they get there but
yeah
they did say they're working on some
deeper matchmaking solutions which
hopefully lets us remove the flawless
pool sometime they're looking mid late
october skill based all right
we'll see we'll see they might just need
more data to like once they have an
update on how good everyone is then i
guess they don't need the flawless pool
anymore i don't know it's a good point
yeah
last stuff they are changing some of it
literally just got patched today i guess
in the big hot fix today players will no
longer get special ammo on replenishment
when being revived which is a big change
i learned that that was even a thing
since i never played trials that much
but that's that's when some people
probably will definitely feel more than
others they added hold function to
purchase gear from saint instead of i
guess you accidentally purchase stuff
from him so they gave you a little
longer hopefully it's that one second
hold on i like that four second really
long hold dismantle an exotic hold yeah
yeah
hold on hold on let me do the dishes
first
weapons received from reputation rank
rewards uh they have their masterwork
slots so the ones up in saints rewards
they have the masterwork slots which is
good uh the cool thing is when you reset
that you actually get different words up
there so it really does yeah i just oh i
did i did reset once i haven't looked
though are they i saw i saw somebody do
basically like hey what do you get when
you reset and you pick it up like not
much changes like big deal but it was
different awards up there because first
it was like the eye of saul and
couldn't remember and then it switched
over and one of them was the messenger
so if you reset enough over the course
of a season
and then finally they said they're
looking forward to uh expect to take
another swim matchmaking to keep some of
the solo lower skill protections from
week two without strongly negatively
affecting flawless players they're
looking at adjustments to rewards for
round and match wins on seven win cards
they definitely need to do that for
flawless because i think the biggest
thing is like if people go flawless and
there's no reason to stay there
or it's just so difficult it's not as
big of a deal but again if you win one
at flawless and you can farm it much
easier the the carrot has to be out
there for people to stay flawless if
it's going to be tough that'll be the
key
uh but outside of that yeah iron banner
is back next week so crucible labs this
week iron banner next week so it'll
return on the 8th
that is most of it for the 12 besides
the giant fashion show which i got to
get tassie's take on because i know
you're the fashionista here let's go
what'd you think about this the way they
kind of managed it i was kind of
confused because i don't know how they
found the first people for the covers
maybe they just reached out to them
themselves and then reading through this
i guess so i guess they pick a number of
people
and who who win and get the emblem but
then only three people one from each
class is on the cover so there will be
a good amount of winners per contest or
something and it sounds like they're
only doing this every couple of months
or something so it's not like a monthly
thing
uh i am obviously all in favor of
anything having to do with more fashion
contests um the the official account
replied to me kind of explaining that
what they do is they
you submit your design and all the
shaders and the things and then they
recreate your look and then do a photo
shoot
for the magazine which is really cool i
think that's
because there's no i wish they would
just give us a photo mode and then we
should just take cool photos ourselves
oh my god give me a photo
a clean hug
been
i think this is cooler than just like
the bungie account retweets you know 10
people in a fashion contest i mean they
could do that too but
i think i leaning into kind of embracing
this is a good idea and also transmog
needs to be free at the end
i don't think you'll get any agreement
this will be the opposite of our trials
debate on transmog should be free
yeah yeah i don't think there's what i
gotta do to enter this i might jump in
what is it you just you just use the
hashtag and then you tag the destiny
account and then you take a screenshot
of your
builds with the on the transmitting
screen so it shows all the people on the
transmission were you defeated this year
paul was i defeated yeah like in the
fashion game yeah like are you are you
on are you on a cover or what
there's only been one issue they just
did it today
[Laughter]
i guess i'm one and one because i have
one fashion emblem and i don't have this
years yet so nice i see i think the one
one is better
i'm trying to win on a titan or a hunter
going forward oh you're gonna go wrong
with the warlocks now
i'm gonna try to keep up with you your
fashion emblems i'm gonna try to keep up
with my movie of the week emblems i'm
just going to okay i have a movie of the
week emblem
you do yeah because i because i was in
uh the dude who does like he's like the
wrong oh
real life yeah
okay
people in the video we all got emblems i
was in that too i was totally cheating
but i'll take it uh i have to win the
art emblem that's what i haven't gotten
yet but i'm not good yeah so that might
be a little while i'm not good at art
well that is that is a bit of a train
myself to be good at art just to win
this it's a bit of a hurdle yeah that's
a bit of a hurdle to get over there
they need a meme emblem i i would love
to agree with them yeah the best meeting
of the week yeah it would just be me and
destiny the meme competing
yeah it would just be a doge
well that pretty much wraps up the twab
we beat trials to death before we even
got to the squad but then we had more
trials
um but i just wanted to ask you guys
like where you guys at for your
expectations for
the rest of the season because you guys
say we got we're in week five
the quest has about two more weeks we're
gonna kind of see that situation wrap up
in october we've got the difficulties
coming for both astral alignment and
then also we've got the legend of
difficulty coming for shattered realm uh
and then grandmaster nightfalls sometime
in december by the calendar that we're
going to be seeing the
new dungeon which i'm still curious
about and then we've also got um
the throne arm or thorn armor and things
like that just where you guys feeling
this whole six month season
how you guys feel this is gonna hit
after a little while
something something's missing here cause
like
i i i don't know what but i think it's
going to be
there there has to be more story stuff i
think that's a given the story can't
just end in three weeks and shut off for
four months there could be some sort of
secret
i mean it's six months you know you
would imagine there's gonna be some sort
of secret thing that happens
uh i i would predict that
the story will end in three weeks
that'll be mid-october
then that's around when festival the law
starts i bet festival of the loss will
probably be that whole month
there probably won't be any story things
that of significance and then with the
difficulty options and gm's
then we'll hit the anniversary and then
all that stuff will drop at once
and then um kind of the real mystery is
what happens from the anniversary to
which game which is like two and a half
three months that is when i would guess
the story would probably pick back up
again we have the dawning but that's not
really anything but an eververse event
and then we have weirdly we have moments
of triumph
which is usually tied to solstice of
heroes but they push it back because the
delay
and that's just kind of like
accomplishing more kind of generic
things throughout the course of the year
but
there has to be more story stuff i and i
i would not
i would not put it past them to do some
sort of secret thing
uh before this the grand season runs out
here
i think it'll i think it'll probably be
pretty boring i think we'll get a
an end and there'll be sort of like a
lull like like paul was saying and then
we'll get our dino armor for festival of
the lost
uh we'll we'll probably be just chilling
for a couple weeks until and hopefully
they're still making trials headlines
and stuff like that uh throughout that
and then i think uh
after
i don't know if the 30th anniversary is
going to be very big i think it might
just be a dungeon and a couple small
activities i don't think it's gonna
is it it's not its own season right
no no it's it's coming at the length of
one no so it's like okay
free activity paid dungeon
i i i don't i mean i don't like it a
story stuff that's just i'm curious
about i mean the dungeon might have some
lore or something but yeah it's gonna be
a season of the lost point five uh and
then yeah i i think there will be some i
think there is some stuff that they're
holding on to for after the 30th
anniversary next year when they get back
from the holidays i think there's going
to be probably a secret event similar to
the whisper of the worm event because
that happened at the end of that season
when people were kind of
just starting to think about destiny
again and height for the future hype for
the future
keep in mind though
they introduced
is getting cut when wish queen hits so
if it's a seasonal thing
it's not going to be around very long so
like the past secret stuff they've done
impressage and stuff like that you know
harbinger those were in the game for a
really long time but anything they
introduced in like january is going to
be cut by
the end of february so that's my only
hesitation where like
i could see that being like story stuff
but i don't know maybe they're not gonna
introduce a whole
secret seasonal mission or something if
it's like a prologue to the witch queen
i think they have to keep it in and i
think that maybe that's cut off and
separated from all the other stuff
that's going out there yeah it could be
a free-to-play
thing that is not part of this
encourages you to buy witch queen and
yeah kind of set up that story and stuff
yeah
yeah yeah just got to see i'm very
curious about the 30th anniversary how
that's implemented probably like you
guys are saying probably not gonna have
any too many story beats or connection
maybe like some separate entity
obviously gallons coming back but i'm
curious about you know the dungeons and
stuff that he's going to be wanting you
know to see so they they're going to be
safe and that need
i think this is a meme filled don't you
like
dungeon it's the loot game dungeon i
think it is yeah well i think i think
it's gonna happen
talking and that's gonna be over the top
i thought they said pirate themed uh
it's it's in the um it's on the uh the
pre-order page
30 years hold on does that even mean a
new dungeon inspired by farmed
cosmodrome loot caves of yore has drawn
the interest of many a treasure huntry
hunter spelunk into the unknown earn the
new thorn armor set and watch your step
as you hunt for lost relics i swear they
said pirate theme somewhere though i
feel like i've heard that that does
sound i mean
are kind
it's probably like it's probably a
fallen dungeon i would imagine even
though it's in a hive cave
yeah that's true yeah it's good but
again for me i'm like
randall the vandal would be the boss
krypt would be great
because that was his whole productions
you should narrate it or
he's uh angry that you're trying to
reclaim gallohorn because it broke the
game last time
that's what i mean i want to i want to
meme dungeon
i want it to be like a borderlands
tiny tina's wonder crazy world mm-hmm
yeah exactly that's it please have fun
with this destiny this is your one
chance bungie to create something yeah
break breakfast
dungeons are like super evil or like
super trippy this one can be like funny
yeah they could do that but yeah i'm
just looking forward to that i'm just
one last question i don't wrap it up so
um do you guys think they will abandon
the um remember the the live events at
the end of a season where they were you
would wait in the tower and something
cataclysmic or the traveler reformed and
before that like but like we wouldn't be
due for one of those at the end of this
season we don't abandon that
i thought those were very cool like i i
i almost i'm sad they haven't done more
of those because it's been such a long
time it was it was since the the
traveler reforms yeah that was the
rivals
yeah full yeah yeah so i i would love to
do something else like that again like i
thought they did a surprisingly good job
and that was before the like the whole
kind of engine overhauls and stuff they
did so i wonder what they could be
capable of now but
it's also hard for me to like think of
what they would do
for the witch screen like we watched
saboteun's throne world be creative
i don't know like that would be a little
yeah
that's kind of the only thing either she
gets out and does something or
the only thing you could probably see is
if you're in the dreaming city when
whatever event goes down
yeah the curse lift or something if
there's something like that that could
be a way to break that finally i don't
know but that might be the only guess of
what but i mean the almighty was too
long we got that but when it happened
was pretty cool the effect the smash
like they even did the sound the
blowback that was actually really cool
and then of course you know seeing the
traveler
wish it would have been more than oh
here's the director getting like you
know overtaken a little more than that
with all the pyramid ships out there in
the sandboxes but our sky boxes
yeah still they were
we are due for one i feel like it would
be a really cool way to go into the
biggest you know expansion they've
probably ever hyped i think yeah i guess
we'll just have to see where the story's
at at that point because like yeah the
main story thing is in the cocoon
obviously sabotaging is coming out of
the cocoon but like clearly that's
that's an instance so like you could go
into that with more than yeah yeah
yourself or another person or something
so
it can't be that so we just don't really
know where the story is
gonna end up so we'll have a better idea
later i think
yeah i don't think they'll do it and
it's not because i don't think it's cool
or would be appropriate i think watching
the curse get lift or something would be
awesome but i just don't think they'll
do it because it seems to me
like that fad
has sort of ended you know what i mean
like a lot of games were trying that
sort of thing for a while where you
could like be in the game and watch
something cool happen and then right you
don't really see that a lot anymore like
fortnite still does it but a lot of a
lot of games were trying it and they've
sort of not done it anymore so i wonder
if it's just sort of like an industry
thing where we kind of moved on and
that's just not something that you mean
the call of duty what was it the
vanguard launch happened in the middle
of war zone recently because they did
like the whole tank
good amount still yeah i mean but yeah
as you said it's not big it's not a lot
of places that do it common anymore
and again it could take a lot of work
that for them they'd rather do these
like well-placed stories for you and
your instance as opposed to this
dramatic thing for more people to see
also covid might make it hard because
yeah they all have to be they all have
to be on site like doing stuff with
good servers yeah that's a good point
yeah i mean it just seems like what week
seven we're going to get grand masters
and then probably wrap up the story week
eight we're going to get festival of the
lost it seems like because if you go to
today in destiny and i think that's when
that's the dino stuff starts coming out
um
so you got you know october you got
difficulties and festival
and november's gonna be probably fairly
light december is gonna be here's your
dungeon at probably the start of
december and then you know dawning and
moments of trying to wrap it up it's
just yeah i'm i'm curious to see what
the story does these next few weeks will
be very interesting to see how much
waiting we have if there's an epilogue
piece if there's any connection to the
30th or it's just this
you know down time to the season of
witch queen
yeah man
well i think that is all we got for this
show
we definitely tapped out the most things
we were trying to yeah yeah somehow we
came out of this thing in one piece but
honestly it's like you guys may hear all
this and if you get to the end of the
show you'd be like man you guys were all
at each other it's like that's part of
the fun it's always good to have debates
and stuff like this because it keeps it
entertaining for you guys you're on one
side or the other i bet you or you're
like maybe i can see both sides but
either way it's been a lot of fun paul
thank you for joining us glad to have
you on again you're you're basically a
friend of the show at this point we got
you not quite regular but you're you're
on here enough it's just i mean this is
you know my favorite show to be on these
days so whenever i can i i i love to be
on oh much appreciated bro as many as
you're on we appreciate that
that's true
i was like i don't know uh cognito may
have uh left us to
higher and brighter places but big boy
now i know really
oh you're hanging out next thing we're
gonna see
moriarty he's gonna have his next tesla
picture on twitter he's like hey check
out my new car
it's still regular
always a pleasure man paul the building
respect for you because um obviously a
huge fan love your takes you're actually
becoming low-key like my favorite
destiny content creator like i literally
look very excited yeah for your videos
because
and i still look i still think
you got the best intro pretend music
that i love that beat whoever pick you
pick that beat or wherever you got it
from don't that's the change jason's
free youtube
that's my joy i love it
okay let's go and then obviously we know
the real star of the show evie we have
to salute i love the birds love what's
going on
okay okay now but salute you bro you've
been killing it the articles and the
content creation we love to see your
journey there and obviously your takes
man it's spicy and uh look anybody could
debate with us and
try to be travis and you go crazy and
still maintain saturday be friends out
it's got to be a friend of the campfire
so salute to my man fall task i always
love when you pull up for sure thanks
for having me no doubt trav what's going
on man what's going on with you
yeah uh you can um follow me on twitter
at thai guy travis i don't have as many
followers as paul i uh
i will gift you
1 000 followers go follow me
i think i think my takes are a little
too controversial i think i don't i
never have controversial takes
yeah that's true that is true
i will give you credit for that i will
give you credit uh but yeah um
and you can find my articles uh reviews
and previews on ign.com uh this week i
reviewed sable i'm doing a preview for a
really interesting uh social deception
game called dread hunger uh and then
also i'm reviewing uh world war z
aftermath uh my review will probably be
up like early next week so got lots of
stuff going on on that end uh and then
i'm on a show called bitcast on sundays
at 8am uh with aims and the boys at
season gaming and uh and you can also
find me here my favorite show the last
word uh spiritual successor to fire team
chat as far as i'm concerned
um
how about you what are you up to buddy
oh there's so much going on i guess luke
pulling up um yeah like this week has
been busy uh check out our defining duke
ultimate we got a sat down with hoge law
we broke down the whole uh legal dispute
which yeah marty o'donnell and uh and
bungie very in-depth lot a lot there
contempt support very messy situation
very cool uh topic by the way yes yes
you got we got to trot that so check
that out and also defining duke itself
my man mr maddie plays that is up
talking about all the latest going on in
the xbox rumors and acquisition stuff
check that out and uh yes sunday will be
iop will return 11 a.m oh thank you guys
for the love obviously we're close to
10k
really means a lot to us as a you know
smaller podcast trying to grow up and
get get a little uh light and stuff like
that so yeah we're close about 50 subs
away nice to be able to go give these
guys yeah
i appreciate that attic king saul those
are my brothers you know those those are
guys we shoot [ __ ] all the time and it's
always fun man it's always fun to to
talk game with them and see the
community that we built so that and then
um yeah you already know the last word
man
living up to its word today
with the spicy i don't know
i think i may have taken the last word
at one point and i was like
let me tell you what i know when i get
when i get travis to yell at me when i
get e to roll no i get i get the paul
tassie iro
and i get e to put the hit do my move
with the when you exasperate it and you
when you get those three things in the
show you know the debate was lit so
salute to the last forever i love what
we're building and i love to see the
growth of people coming in here and
saying what they guys even when they
agree disagree it's fun it's all love at
the end of the day so appreciate all the
support y'all and e what's going on with
you man
uh yeah let's see i built a couch that
was fun i'm about to go build a hutch i
don't know if you guys saw that on
twitter so if you guys ever heard of the
company lovesack um it's a hilarious
name by the way i'll give them props for
that they build like you know giant
modern memory foam bean bags well they
do a sectional as their brand
you can get it
[Laughter]
but you get a couch in 18 boxes so you
have like the seats the cushions are
inside the seats you pull those out
you're actually so they send you like
the covers the frames and then the side
panels and you put it all together so we
have this brand new couch that we've
been waiting on forever but you can
rearrange it however you want because
it's just these little panels inside so
you can do like mix and match my wife
has like a little reading chair now okay
we can turn it into like a fainting
couch all the you can just it's
i don't think they gave you a couchy i
think they gave you a day job it sounded
like they did yeah they're they're
making they're making
yeah i'm like full-time
full-time labor in here so yeah they
just they were like well we can't afford
a warehouse what are we going to do guys
oh what if we just make them build it
we'll just send them all the pieces and
they can figure it out
i haven't given you the creepy picture
yet but i thought since i can actually
lay lengthwise on it about doing the
bert reynolds for you i was going to go
for that please i want i want to follow
up to you lying in that creepy coffin
box okay that one okay i built a murphy
bed like in our guest room gives us a
little more room you know place to work
out my wife did yoga and stuff like that
but the big bad folds
that was a 500 pound crate when it was
shipped
that was insane to put that thing
together but like the box was big enough
you could put me inside it and i'd get
lost so that's why that was there these
were much smaller
but yeah after i'm done building
furniture uh i gotta finish kenna about
about five hours in i hear it's about
twice as long as that so that'll be good
um new worlds around the corner i'm
still debating on that one because you
know we're gonna have some down time in
this game so i'm still not entirely sure
where that's gonna go uh but other than
that as you guys know i'm no longer at
my kickboxing studio so i'm doing this
all the time now so
this is what i got going on so if you
guys want to find all of these amazing
people please support all of them tassie
go find his articles and hit refresh
four times until forbes blocks you out
support
hardest working man in show business
incognito mode incognito mode then go on
your phone just refresh back and forth
for travis go find his review on ign
just hit a bot to hit refresh bump those
views up and as for cog please please go
subscribe to iron lord's podcast youtube
channel go find some views on on um
log now that's what i was gonna call it
but lords of gaming.
no but the last one is um support this
man in the high profile work that he's
doing over at last stand media great
group of guys over there enjoying
enjoying basically making you guys one
of my xbox podcasts to kind of you know
fill everything in so
defining duke and collin and everybody
it's
there's a lot of amazing creators in the
world and i'm lucky enough to sit with
three on this podcast so thank you all
for being here again it's you know my
pleasure of course always love always
love brother well for episode number 167
tassie thank you for coming in as always
we'll get you in here as much as you
want to be so if you ever like dude i
want it fun to like let us know you're
always invited travis we could jump
travis again
i'm used to being on the uh the minority
side of the artist
we love the passion regardless
well thank you guys so much we'll wrap
this one up here silver episode 167
september 23rd amazing guest amazing
times and a new debate lived up to it
thank you all have a good one and for
this episode it has been
the last word